ALL RIGHT. THE JOINT SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES ON PUBLIC
SAFETY INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
PROP 36. HAS BEGUN, WE ARE A
LITTLE BIT PAST TIME, AND I WANT
TO KEEP A STRICT TIME JUST FOR
THOSE THAT HAVE ARRIVED,
ACTUALLY ON TIME, I DO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF GROUND
RULES. NUMBER ONE, WE ARE GOING
TO TRY TO KEEP IT AS CONCISE,
BOTH IN THE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS, BUT ALSO IN THE
PRESENTATION TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE HAS A CHANCE TO SPEAK,
I DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
PUBLIC COMMENTS WILL BE AT THE
VERY END, AND WE WILL ONLY BE
ASKING FOR NAME POTENTIAL
ORGANIZATION IF SOMEBODY BELONGS
TO AN ORGANIZATION AND WHETHER
OR NOT THEY SUPPORT. SO THEIR
POSITION, WE'RE GOING TO KEEP IT
VERY BRIEF BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
WANT TO SPEAK ON THE ITEM. I
WILL JUST GO OVER THE AGENDA
VERY QUICKLY. THIS IS AN
OVERVIEW OF PROP 36, WHICH
ALLOWS FELONY CHARGES AND
INCREASES SENTENCES FOR CERTAIN
DRUG AND THEFT CRIMES. WE'RE
FIRST GOING TO HAVE OPENING
REMARKS BY COMMITTEE CHAIRS AS
WELL AS PART TWO WILL BE THE
ANALYSIS OF THE MEASURE BY THE
LA OES OFFICE. AND THEN PART
THREE WILL BE PROPONENTS OF THE
MEASURE. WE'LL HAVE THREE
SPEAKERS AND OPPONENTS OF THE
MEASURE WILL AGAIN HAVE THREE
SPEAKERS. AND THEN PUBLIC
COMMENTS. THE PRESENTATIONS OF
THESE SPEAKERS WILL BE AT THAT
PODIUM ONE BY ONE. AND EACH OF
THEM HAVE BEEN TOLD THE TIME
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE HAVING
TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK AND SHARE
THEIR VIEWPOINTS AND PRESENT
WHAT THEY NEED TO PRESENT, I DO
WANT TO SAY AGAIN THAT COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WILL TRY TO KEEP THEIR
COMMENTS BRIEF AND CONCISE. I DO
ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
THERE ARE SOME COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THAT WILL JOIN US EITHER LATER,
OR MAY HAVE TO STEP OUT. THIS IS
VERY COMMON AS THERE ARE A LOT
OF COMPETING, SCHEDULES AND SO
FORTH. SO I JUST WANT TO BE VERY
TRANSPARENT IN THAT. AND I WILL
BEGIN WITH THIS BALLOT MEASURE
WOULD MAKE CHANGES TO LAWS
ENACTED BY PROP 47, WHICH WAS
VOTED INTO LAW IN 2014 BY
INCREASING PENALTIES FOR CERTAIN
THEFT AND DRUG CRIMES, AND
REQUIRES SOME OF THESE CRIMES TO
BE PUNISHED IN STATE PRISON
RATHER THAN COUNTY JAIL. THIS
MEASURE WOULD ALSO MANDATE DRUG
TREATMENT FOR SPECIFIED DRUG
CRIMES, AND REQUIRE COURTS TO
GIVE DEFENDANTS A WARNING OF
POSSIBLE MURDER CHARGES IN THE
FUTURE FOR SELLING OR PROVIDING
DRUGS TO ANOTHER. CALIFORNIA HAS
STRUGGLED IN THE PAST TO REFORM
ITS PRISON SYSTEM AFTER BEING
HELD BY THE U.S. SUPREME COURT
TO BE SO OVERCROWDED THAT
CONDITIONS VIOLATED THE EIGHTH
AMENDMENT'S BAN ON CRUEL AND
UNUSUAL PUNISHMENT. CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM MEASURES SUCH AS
PROP 47 HAVE ALLOWED CALIFORNIA
TO FALL WITHIN THE COURT ORDERED
POPULATION CAP AND STRENGTHEN
PROGRAMS THAT FOCUS ON
REHABILITATION. ANY ATTEMPTS TO
ROLL BACK THOSE REFORMS IS VERY
MUCH IN THE INTEREST OF THE
PUBLIC AND SHOULD BE REVIEWED
VERY CAREFULLY. THAT IS THE
PURPOSE OF THIS HEARING. IT'S TO
HAVE A PUBLIC DISCUSSION OF THE
PROPOSED BALLOT MEASURE AND HEAR
TESTIMONY FROM VARIOUS
PERSPECTIVES IMPACTED BY THE
MEASURE. AS WE HEAR THE
TESTIMONY, LET'S KEEP IN MIND
THAT PUBLIC SAFETY IS SOMETHING
THAT WE ALL CARE ABOUT, EVEN IF
WE SOMETIMES DISAGREE ON WHAT IS
THE BEST APPROACH TODAY, WE WILL
START WITH AN OVERVIEW OF THE
BALLOT MEASURE FROM THE LA OES
OFFICE. THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. THEN WE WILL
HEAR FROM PROPONENTS AND
OPPONENTS OF THE MEASURE. THERE
WILL BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END. AS I
STATED, WE'RE GOING TO ONLY ASK
FOR THEIR NAME. THE POTENTIAL
ORGANIZATION AND WHAT THEIR
POSITION IS. BEFORE I GET TO
PANELISTS, I'D LIKE TO PROVIDE
THE CHAIR OF ASSEMBLY PUBLIC
SAFETY A CHANCE TO MAKE ANY
COMMENTS AND THEN OPEN IT UP TO
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR ANY COMMENTS. CHAIR. YES,
THANK YOU. CHAIR. WAHAB. AND YOU
CERTAINLY, I THINK, LAID IT OUT
SO I'LL BE BRIEF. AND THIS IS A
JOINT HEARING WITH THE ASSEMBLY
AND SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEES. THIS IS PART OF OUR
STATUTORY ROLE TO HAVE AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
MEASURES BEFORE THE VOTERS. SO
CERTAINLY WE HAVE OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO THE LEGISLATURE
TO CREATE OUR LAWS AND THIS IS
THE PUBLIC'S OPPORTUNITY THROUGH
DIRECT DEMOCRACY BY PUTTING A
MEASURE ON THE BALLOT. SO WE
WORKED ON A ROBUST MEASURE. THIS
MEASURES THIS YEAR TO INCREASE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR RETAIL THEFT
AND DRUG USE. AND CERTAINLY THE
ELECTORATE HAS THE RIGHT TO PUT
THEIR OWN MEASURE ON THE BALLOT.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
BE DOING TODAY. TALKING ABOUT
THE PROS AND CONS, HEARING FROM
OUR LEGISLATIVE ANALYSTS,
TALKING ABOUT THE FISCAL IMPACT.
AND WITH THAT, I LOOK FORWARD TO
THE CONVERSATION AND LET'S GET
GOING. CHAIR THANK YOU.
DEFINITELY. THANK YOU. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO START OUT?
SEEING NONE WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO OUR VERY FIRST PRESENTER.
AGAIN, YOU WILL BE PRESENTING AT
THAT PODIUM. THIS IS CAITLIN
O'NEILL, PRINCIPAL FISCAL AND
POLICY ANALYST OF THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
YOU ARE TIMED AND I BELIEVE THAT
YOU WERE INFORMED HOW MUCH TIME
YOU HAVE AND TO BE VERY CLEAR, I
BELIEVE IT'S UP TO 15 MINUTES,
UP TO 15 MINUTES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. CAITLIN
O'NEILL WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. I'LL BE
SPEAKING TODAY FROM A HANDOUT
WHICH IS AVAILABLE IN HARD COPY
WITH THE SERGEANTS AS WELL AS ON
OUR WEBSITE, LOCAL GOV. UNDER
THE PUBLICATIONS TAB. I'M MOVING
TO PAGE ONE. I'M GOING TO
PROVIDE A VERY BRIEF OVERVIEW
OVERVIEW OF OUR OFFICE'S ROLE IN
THE INITIATIVE PROCESS, WHICH IS
AT TWO STAGES. FIRST, STATE LAW
REQUIRES OUR OFFICE TO WORK WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
PREPARE A JOINT AND PARTIAL
FISCAL ANALYSIS OF EACH
INITIATIVE TO BE INCLUDED ON THE
PETITIONS THAT ARE CIRCULATED
FOR SIGNATURE GATHERING. THE
SECOND STAGE IS OF OUR OFFICE'S
INVOLVEMENT IS THAT STATE LAW
REQUIRES US TO PROVIDE IMPARTIAL
ANALYZES OF ALL QUALIFIED,
QUALIFIED, STATEWIDE BALLOT
PROPOSITIONS FOR THE VOTER
INFORMATION GUIDE. THIS ANALYSIS
INCLUDES A DESCRIPTION OF THE
PROPOSITION AND ITS FISCAL
EFFECTS ON THE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. AND THAT'S WHAT I'LL
BE TALKING ABOUT TODAY. MOVING
TO PAGE TWO, I'M GOING TO
PROVIDE SOME VERY BRIEF,
BACKGROUND, WHICH IS THAT
PUNISHMENT GENERALLY DEPENDS ON
THE SERIOUSNESS OF THE CRIME AND
THE PERSON'S CRIMINAL HISTORY.
SO PUNISHMENT FOR FELONIES CAN
INCLUDE SENTENCE A SENTENCE TO
COUNTY JAIL OR STATE PRISON,
DEPENDING ON THE PERSON'S CRIME
AND THEIR CRIMINAL HISTORY. IN
SOME CASES, PEOPLE CAN BE
SUPERVISED IN THE COMMUNITY IN
LIEU OF SERVING SOME OR ALL OF
THEIR SENTENCE IN JAIL OR
PRISON. THE LENGTH OF THE
SENTENCE MOSTLY DEPENDS ON THE
CRIME. SO, FOR EXAMPLE, A
SENTENCE FOR MURDER COULD BE 15
YEARS OR MORE IN STATE PRISON,
WHEREAS A SENTENCE FOR SELLING
DRUGS COULD BE UP TO FIVE YEARS
IN JAIL OR PRISON, DEPENDING ON
THE PERSON'S CRIMINAL HISTORY.
SENTENCES, HOWEVER, CAN BE
LENGTHENED BASED ON DETAILS OF
THE CRIME. THIS IS CALLED AN
ENHANCEMENT OFTENTIMES SO FOR
EXAMPLE, SELLING CERTAIN DRUGS
CAN IF THE PERSON SELLS A VERY
LARGE QUANTITY OF DRUGS, CAN BE
LENGTHENED. IN ADDITION TO THE
BASE TERM FOR DRUG SALES, BASED
ON THE AMOUNT OF DRUGS THAT THE
PERSON SOLD, PEOPLE SENTENCED,
OR PEOPLE CONVICTED OF
MISDEMEANORS CAN BE SENTENCED TO
COUNTY JAIL. COMMUNITY
SUPERVISION, AND OR A FINE, AND
SENTENCES FOR A MISDEMEANOR CAN
BE UP TO ONE YEAR IN JAIL. IN
2014, PROPOSITION 47 REDUCED
VARIOUS CRIMES FROM THEFT AND
DRUG CRIMES FROM FELONIES TO
MISDEMEANORS. EXAMPLES INCLUDE
SHOPLIFTING AND SIMPLE DRUG
POSSESSION. MOVING ON TO PAGE
THREE, I'M GOING TO PROVIDE A
HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW OF WHAT
PROPOSITION 36 WOULD DO. IT
WOULD MAKE VARIOUS CHANGES TO
STATE LAW THAT GENERALLY FALL
INTO KIND OF THREE COMPONENTS.
SO THE FIRST COMPONENT IS THAT
THE MEASURE WOULD INCREASE
PUNISHMENT FOR SOME THEFT AND
DRUG CRIMES, AND IT WOULD DO SO
IN THREE GENERAL WAYS. THE FIRST
WAY THAT IT WOULD INCREASE
PUNISHMENT IS THAT IT WOULD
CONVERT SOME MISDEMEANOR CRIMES
INTO FELONIES. SO, FOR EXAMPLE,
AS I MENTIONED, SHOPLIFTING IS
GENERALLY A MISDEMEANOR UNDER
CURRENT LAW. UNDER PROP 36, IF
THE PERSON HAS TWO OR MORE PAST
CONVICTIONS FOR CERTAIN THEFT
CRIMES, THAT PERSON COULD BE
CHARGED WITH A FELONY. THESE
CHANGES THAT SHIFT SOME
MISDEMEANORS TO FELONIES WOULD
UNDO SOME OF THE PUNISHMENT
REDUCTIONS THAT WERE IN
PROPOSITION 47. THE SECOND WAY
THAT PROP 36 WOULD INCREASE
PUNISHMENT IS THAT IT WOULD
LENGTHEN SOME FELONY SENTENCES.
SO, FOR EXAMPLE, PROPOSITION 36
WOULD ALLOW FELONY SENTENCES FOR
THEFT OR DAMAGE OF PROPERTY TO
BE LENGTHENED BY UP TO THREE
YEARS. IF THREE OR MORE PEOPLE
COMMITTED THE CRIME TOGETHER.
AND THE THIRD WAY THAT THE
MEASURE WOULD INCREASE
PUNISHMENT IS THAT IT WOULD
REQUIRE SOME FELONIES TO BE
SERVED IN PRISON, REGARDLESS OF
THE PERSON'S CRIMINAL HISTORY OR
SOME FELONY SENTENCES. I SHOULD
SAY. SO. FOR EXAMPLE, AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER, UNDER CURRENT
LAW, PEOPLE WHO SELL VERY LARGE
QUANTITIES OF CERTAIN TYPES OF
DRUGS CAN HAVE THEIR SENTENCES
LENGTHENED OR ENHANCED. AS AS
YOU MAY CAN REFER TO IT. BASED
ON THE QUANTITY OF THE DRUGS
SOLD. CURRENTLY. THESE SENTENCES
ARE SERVED IN EITHER JAIL OR
PRISON, DEPENDING ON THE
PERSON'S CRIMINAL HISTORY. UNDER
PROP 36, THEY WOULD GENERALLY BE
REQUIRED TO SERVE THAT SENTENCE
IN PRISON REGARDLESS OF THEIR
CRIMINAL HISTORY. MOVING ON TO
THE SECOND KIND OF MAIN
COMPONENT OF THE MEASURE, WHICH
IS THAT IT CREATES A NEW COURT
PROCESS FOR SOME DRUG POSSESSION
CRIMES. SO, AS I MENTIONED,
SIMPLE POSSESSION OF DRUGS IS
GENERALLY A MISDEMEANOR UNDER
CURRENT LAW. UNDER PROP 36, IF A
PERSON POSSESSES CERTAIN TYPES
OF DRUGS THAT THE MEASURE DEEMS
HARD DRUGS, WHICH INCLUDES
FENTANYL, HEROIN, COCAINE, AND
METHAMPHETAMINE, AND THEY HAVE
TWO OR MORE PRIOR CONVICTIONS
FOR, A CERTAIN DRUG CRIMES LIKE
POSSESSION OR SALE. THEY COULD
BE CHARGED WITH WHAT THE MEASURE
TERMS A TREATMENT MANDATED
FELONY. THESE PEOPLE WOULD
GENERALLY GET TREATMENT SUCH AS
MENTAL HEALTH OR DRUG TREATMENT,
AND THOSE WHO FINISH TREATMENT
COULD HAVE THEIR CHARGE OR WOULD
HAVE THEIR CHARGES DISMISSED.
THOSE WHO DO NOT FINISH
TREATMENT COULD SERVE UP TO
THREE YEARS IN STATE PRISON.
THIS IS ANOTHER ONE OF THE
CHANGES IN THE MEASURE THAT
WOULD UNDO SOME OF THE
PUNISHMENT REDUCTIONS THAT WERE
IN PROP 47. TURNING TO PAGE FOUR
TO THE THIRD COMPONENT OF THE
MEASURE, WHICH IS THAT IT WOULD
REQUIRE COURTS TO WARN PEOPLE
THAT THEY COULD BE CHARGED WITH
MURDER IF THEY SELL OR PROVIDE
ILLEGAL DRUGS THAT KILL SOMEONE
IN THE FUTURE, THIS WOULD
WARNING WOULD BE GIVEN TO PEOPLE
CONVICTED, CONVICTED OF SELLING
OR PROVIDING THOSE DRUGS THAT
THE MEASURE DEEMS HARD DRUGS
MOVING TO PAGE FIVE, WE'LL GET
INTO OUR ESTIMATE OF THE
MEASURES. FISCAL EFFECTS ON THE
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT, IT
WOULD INCREASE STATE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE COSTS IN TWO PRIMARY
WAYS. THE FIRST IS THAT IT WOULD
INCREASE THE STATE PRISON
POPULATION. IT WOULD DO SO BY,
AS I MENTIONED, SHIFTING SOME
SENTENCES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
SERVED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO THE
STATE PRISON. IT WOULD ALSO
LENGTHEN THE AMOUNT OF TIME THAT
SOME PEOPLE WHO GO TO PRISON,
UNDER CURRENT LAW, SPEND THEIR,
IN TOTAL, WE ESTIMATE IT COULD
INCREASE THE PRISON POPULATION
BY AROUND A FEW THOUSAND PEOPLE.
THE SECOND WAY IT WOULD INCREASE
STATE COSTS IS BY INCREASING
STATE COURT WORKLOAD. AND THAT'S
BECAUSE MISDEMEANOR FELONIES
TAKE LONGER TO PROCESS THAN
MISDEMEANORS. AND THIS MEASURE
WOULD CONVERT SOME CASES FROM
MISDEMEANORS TO FELONIES. IN
TOTAL, WE ESTIMATE THAT, THE
INCREASE IN STATE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE COSTS LIKELY WOULD RANGE
FROM THE SEVERAL TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO THE LOW
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. THE MEASURE WOULD ALSO
INCREASE LOCAL CRIMINAL JUSTICE
COSTS, AND IT WOULD DO SO IN TWO
WAYS. THE FIRST WOULD BE A NET
INCREASE IN THE COUNTY JAIL AND
COMMUNITY SUPERVISION
POPULATION. AND THE REASON I SAY
NET THERE IS BECAUSE THE MEASURE
WOULD HAVE SOME OF THE DIFFERENT
CHANGES IN THE MEASURE WOULD
HAVE, COUNTERVAILING, IMPACTS ON
THE LOCAL POPULATION. THAT'S
BECAUSE IT WOULD SHIFT SOME
PEOPLE FROM LOCAL, THE LOCAL
LEVEL TO STATE PRISON, WHICH
WOULD OF COURSE REDUCE HAVE THE
EFFECT OF REDUCING LOCAL
POPULATIONS. ON THE OTHER HAND,
IT WOULD CAUSE SOME PEOPLE WHO
STAY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO SPEND
MORE TIME IN JAIL OR ON
SUPERVISION, WHICH WOULD HAVE
THE EFFECT OF INCREASING
POPULATIONS. WE THINK THAT ON
NET, THERE COULD BE AN INCREASE
OF AROUND A FEW THOUSAND PEOPLE
IN THE TOTAL, COUNTY JAIL AND
COMMUNITY SUPERVISION
POPULATION. THE MEASURE WOULD
ALSO INCREASE LOCAL COURT
RELATED WORKLOAD, JUST LIKE IT
INCREASED THE STATE WORKLOAD.
THE COUNTY ACTORS INVOLVED IN
HANDLING MISDEMEANOR AND FELONY
CASES WOULD, SUCH AS THE PUBLIC
DEFENDERS AND THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICES, WOULD, WOULD
ALSO EXPERIENCE SOME INCREASED
WORKLOAD. AND THEN FINALLY, THE
TREATMENT MANDATED FELONY COULD
CREATE WORKLOAD FOR, SOME COUNTY
AGENCIES LIKE PROBATION OR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
THAT ARE INVOLVED IN PROVIDING
THE SERVICES. WE ESTIMATE THAT
PROP 36, IN TOTAL WOULD INCREASE
LOCAL CRIMINAL JUSTICE COSTS,
LIKELY BY THE TENS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ANNUALLY. AND
FINALLY, MOVING TO PAGE SIX, THE
MEASURE WOULD REDUCE THE AMOUNT
THAT THE STATE MUST SPEND ON
CERTAIN SERVICES DUE TO
REQUIREMENTS IN EXISTING LAW.
AND TO EXPLAIN THAT, I'LL JUST
TOUCH ON VERY BRIEFLY SOME
ADDITIONAL BACKGROUND, WHICH IS
THAT PROPOSITION 47 CREATED A
PROCESS IN WHICH THE ESTIMATED
STATE SAVINGS FROM ITS
PUNISHMENT REDUCTIONS MUST BE
SPENT ON CERTAIN SERVICES AND TO
GIVE CONTEXT, THOSE ESTIMATED
SAVINGS TOTALED $95 MILLION LAST
YEAR. SO MOVING BACK INTO WHAT
PROP 36 WOULD DO BY UNDOING SOME
PORTIONS OF THE PUNISHMENT
REDUCTIONS THAT WERE IN PROP 47,
PROP 36 WOULD REDUCE THE SAVINGS
ATTRIBUTABLE TO THE PROP 47,
WHICH WOULD REDUCE THE AMOUNT
THAT THE STATE MUST SPEND ON
THOSE DESIGNATED PROGRAMS. WE
ESTIMATE THE REDUCTION WOULD
LIKELY BE IN THE LOW TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
THAT BRINGS ME TO THE END OF MY
PREPARED COMMENTS, AND I'M HAPPY
TO TRY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU, DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE? CHAIR.
YEAH, I WANT TO START OUT BY, BY
ASKING ON THE ESTIMATES FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS. SO
CLEARLY, IF THERE'S MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY, WHICH MEANS
INCARCERATION, THAT WOULD COST
MORE. AND YOU KNOW, I GUESS
WE'LL HEAR FROM THE PROPONENTS A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE DESIRE TO
HAVE TREATMENT ON THAT SIDE, I
WAS JUST CURIOUS, HOW DO WE COME
TO THE ESTIMATES FOR INCREASED
INCARCERATION AT STATE PRISON
VERSUS COUNTY JAIL? IN OTHER
WORDS, MANY OF THESE LOWER LEVEL
FELONIES THROUGH, YOU KNOW,
REALIGNMENT AND AB109 HAVE BEEN
KICKED DOWN TO COUNTY JAIL
ANYWAY. SO STATE PRISON IS
SUPPOSED TO BE FOR SERIOUS
OFFENSES. AND WE'VE HAD COUNTY
JAIL POPULATIONS INCREASE FOR
SOME OF THESE LOWER LEVELS. SO
AND OF COURSE, STATE PRISON IS
$130,000 ROUGHLY A YEAR. COUNTY
JAIL IS MUCH LESS SO HOW DO WE
HOW DO WE ASSUME HOW MANY
PEOPLE, IF THEY ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR REPEAT
OFFENSES, WOULD GO TO STATE
PRISON VERSUS COUNTY JAIL? SO
WE, FOR EACH OF THE DIFFERENT
SENTENCING CHANGES IN THE
MEASURE, WE ATTEMPT TO USE DATA,
WHATEVER DATA IS AVAILABLE,
WHICH OFTEN INVOLVES FOR US A,
REQUEST TO DOJ TO GIVE US
CONVICTION DATA FOR THE SPECIFIC
OFFENSES THAT WOULD BE AFFECTED
BY THAT PARTICULAR CHANGE, OR
SOMETHING THAT IS AS CLOSE TO IT
AS WE CAN GET. WE ALSO WORK WITH
CDCR TO GET DATA ON THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE CERTAIN
ENHANCEMENTS THAT COULD BE
AFFECTED BY THE MEASURE. IN SOME
CASES, LIKE WITH THE LOCAL, THE
POPULATION THAT'S CURRENTLY IN
LOCAL JAILS, WE DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE THERE ISN'T
MUCH STATEWIDE DATA AVAILABLE ON
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WITH
ENHANCEMENTS THERE. FOR EXAMPLE,
SO WE ESSENTIALLY WE USE
WHATEVER DATA WE CAN THAT EXISTS
THAT WE CAN FIND THAT GETS US AS
CLOSE TO AS POSSIBLE THE
POPULATIONS THAT WOULD BE
AFFECTED BY EACH OF THESE
DIFFERENT MEASURES. AND WE MAP
OUT, BASED ON THAT, BASED ON
KIND OF HOW THE MEASURE WOULD
CHANGE PEOPLE'S ROUTING IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. WE
ATTEMPT TO ESTIMATE AND KEEP
TRACK OF THE DIFFERENT CHANGING
AND CASELOAD OF JAIL FELONY
PROBATION, POST-RELEASE
COMMUNITY SUPERVISION, PRISON,
SO IT'S QUITE IT'S REALLY LIKE
TEN DIFFERENT ESTIMATES WITHIN
ONE. GIVEN THAT THE MEASURE HAS
VARIOUS DIFFERENT CHANGES AND
THEY EACH WORK IN DIFFERENT
WAYS. AND THEN WE CALCULATE THE
NET EFFECT, THERE'S A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY IN AREAS WHERE WE
JUST SIMPLY DON'T HAVE DATA. AND
SO IN THOSE CASES WE TALKED TO
VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS. LOOK AT
RESEARCH, DO OUR BEST TO TRY TO
COME UP WITH WHAT WE THINK ARE
SOME REASONABLE PARAMETERS, AND
THEN WE SENSITIVITY TEST TO SEE
HOW MUCH CHANGING THOSE FACTORS
AFFECTS OUR BOTTOM LINE
ESTIMATE. AND WE ALSO, AS YOU
SEE, GIVE A RANGE WHICH WE THINK
IS REFLECTIVE OF KIND OF THE
AMOUNT OF UNCERTAINTY THAT
EXISTS BASED ON THE UNKNOWN
FACTORS. DOES THAT ADDRESS YOUR
A LITTLE BIT. SO IT'S MORE OF AN
ART THAN A SCIENCE. AND ALSO I'M
SURE IT VARIES COUNTY TO COUNTY
DEPENDING ON THE COUNTY JAIL
POPULATION. SO WHEN YOU FOCUS ON
THE TENS OF MILLIONS AND
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS, IS THAT IN
COST TO SOCIETY? AND TAXPAYERS
IN GENERAL, OR IS THAT STATE
COST ADDED IN WITH POTENTIAL
LOCAL COSTS? HOW DO YOU KIND OF
ADD ALL THIS UP? WE ARE SO THE
OUR TASK IS TO REPORT ON THE
FISCAL ESTIMATE, THE FISCAL
EFFECTS FOR THE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. AND SO THE, THE
RANGES THAT YOU SEE HERE ON PAGE
FIVE OF THE HANDOUT, THE FIRST
SECTION IS THE ESTIMATE OF THE
STATE COSTS, AND THEN THE BOTTOM
SECTION IS OUR ESTIMATE OF THE
TOTAL COST TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS,
WHICH AND WE DON'T WE DON'T
ATTEMPT TO BREAK OUT BY COUNTY.
SO THAT'S FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AS A WHOLE OKAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR NIELLO. THANK
YOU. JUST ONE QUESTION KIND OF
RELATED TO THE PREVIOUS
QUESTIONS WITH REGARD TO PRISON
POPULATION, IN YOUR ANALYSIS,
YOU'VE INDICATED THAT IT COULD
INCREASE PRISON POPULATION BY A
FEW THOUSAND AT THE STATE IN
STATE PRISONS AND BY A FEW
THOUSAND IN, IN LOCAL JAILS.
WHEN YOU PRESENTED, I THOUGHT I
HEARD YOU SAY 2000, BUT WHEN YOU
SAY IF YOU GAVE A RANGE WITH
REGARD TO DOLLARS, IS THERE A
RANGE THAT YOU THINK IS RELEVANT
TO THAT FEW THOUSAND FIGURE? AND
IS IT CLOSER TO THE 2000 THAT I
THOUGHT I HEARD YOU SAY A RANGE
IN THE, POPULATION NUMBERS OR IN
THE DOLLARS, IT'S A FEW WE I
DIDN'T I DIDN'T INTEND TO SAY
TOO. IF I DID, THAT WAS A
MISTAKE. I MAY HAVE MISHEARD, WE
CONSIDER IT TO BE A FEW, WHICH
IS SORT OF WHAT A GENERAL
AVERAGE VOTER THINKS OF OR WHAT
WE HOPE THE GENERAL VOTER THINKS
OF WHEN THEY SEE THE WORD A FEW.
SO LIKE 2 TO 5, PERHAPS
SOMETHING LIKE THAT, THE REASON
AND THEN WE TRANSLATE THAT INTO
DOLLARS BY LOOKING, MAKING,
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT OR CONSIDERING
THE RANGE OF PLAUSIBLE
POSSIBILITIES AROUND HOW SUCH A
REDUCTION IN THE OR INCREASE IN
THE POPULATION WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED BY CDCR. WHETHER
THAT'S JUST SIMPLY MORE FOOD,
CLOTHES, MORE, YOU KNOW, FOR
ADDITIONAL INCARCERATED PEOPLE
THAT JUST FILL IN SLOTS OF
EXISTING FACILITIES, THAT'S A
LOWER COST MULTIPLIER, OR TO THE
EXTENT THAT THAT FEW THOUSAND
LED TO, PERHAPS SOME FACILITIES
THAT WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE BEEN
CLOSED, NOT BEING CLOSED, THEN
THAT'S A HIGHER COST DOLLAR
VALUE MULTIPLIER BECAUSE WE'RE
TALKING FIXED COSTS OR OVERHEAD
COSTS. SO THAT'S HOW WE GET FROM
AND WE CONSIDER KIND OF THAT,
THAT WHOLE RANGE OF
POSSIBILITIES IN THE CONTEXT OF
CDCR, AND THAT'S HOW WE GET FROM
A FEW THOUSAND TO THE DOLLAR
VALUE RANGE THAT YOU SEE THERE.
DID I HEAR YOU SAY THAT IN THE,
THE DOLLAR RANGE THAT FIXED
COSTS WOULD BE INCLUDED IN THAT
CALCULATION IN THE UPPER END OF
IT? IF TO THE EXTENT BASICALLY
WE ARE, AS WE TYPICALLY DO WHEN
WE ARE ESTIMATING, TRYING TO PUT
A DOLLAR TO POPULATION CHANGES,
WE THINK ABOUT HOW MIGHT THIS BE
IMPLEMENTED, WHAT WOULD BE THE
HOW THE HOUSING IMPLEMENTATION
IMPLICATIONS FOR CDCR? AND
THERE'S KIND OF TWO
POSSIBILITIES THERE, GIVEN THAT
A FEW THOUSAND IS ROUGHLY THE
SIZE OF ONE PRISON, SO AND THE
STATE HAS BEEN KIND OF IN THE
PROCESS OF, CLOSING FACILITIES.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO KNOW. WE
CAN'T PREDICT THE FUTURE. SO WE
JUST CONSIDER IT'S ONE, ONE OF
VARIOUS AREAS OF UNCERTAINTY IN
OUR IN OUR ESTIMATE. THAT'S PART
OF THIS TASK. YEAH. THANK YOU,
SO I WOULD LIKE TO UNDERSTAND A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT DO WE HAVE AN
ESTIMATE OF WHAT THE NEW DRUG
TREATMENT PROGRAM WOULD COST TO
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT, WE DIDN'T
ESTIMATE THAT, THAT COMPONENT OF
THE MEASURE SPECIFICALLY, OR AT
LEAST WE THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT
PART OF THE LOCAL COST, THOUGH I
WILL SAY SO. I MEAN, THAT'S
THAT'S ONE AREA OF, OF A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY BECAUSE WE DON'T
KNOW HOW WE HAVE WE DO ESTIMATE
HOW MANY PEOPLE WE THINK MIGHT
BE ELIGIBLE FOR THAT BASED ON
CONVICTION DATA, BUT IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO KNOW WHAT TYPES OF
SERVICES THEY WOULD BE
RECEIVING, SINCE THE MEASURE IS
FAIRLY OPEN ENDED ABOUT WHAT YOU
KNOW, WHAT WHAT SERVICES THEY
WOULD RECEIVE. IT WOULD DEPEND
ON IMPLEMENTATION, THE NEEDS OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS, WHAT SERVICES
ARE AVAILABLE, SO WHEN YOU SAY
WHAT SERVICES ARE AVAILABLE AT
AT THESE LEVELS, COULD YOU
ELABORATE? I'M JUST BASICALLY
SAYING THAT THE COST OF THAT
COMPONENT OF THE MEASURE WOULD
DEPEND ON IMPLEMENTATION AND THE
ACTUAL SERVICES THAT PEOPLE
RECEIVE, BUT DO WE KNOW WHAT
SERVICES WOULD BE PROVIDED? IT'S
NOT CLEAR. I MEAN, WE'RE JUST
GOING OFF OF, BASED ON THE TEXT
OF THE MEASURE, WHICH REQUIRES A
AN EVALUATION BY A MENTAL HEALTH
AND DRUG EXPERT, SUBSTANCE USE
EXPERT, I BELIEVE IS AND THEN
SAYS KIND OF THE SERVICES CAN
INCLUDE VARIOUS THINGS,
INCLUDING HOUSING, TRAINING AND
SORT OF NOT. IT'S NOT LIMITED TO
THESE THESE TYPES OF SERVICES,
IF I RECALL CORRECTLY. AND THE
SERVICES WOULD BE PROVIDED AT A
LOCAL LEVEL OR AT THE STATE
PRISON FACILITIES. SO THESE
PEOPLE, BECAUSE THE TREATMENT
MANDATED FELONY, WOULD,
BASICALLY SAY THAT IT IS THE
DEFAULT FOR THESE PEOPLE TO HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR TREATMENT IN
LIEU OF BEING CONVICTED, AT
LEAST AS A, YOU KNOW, AS A FIRST
SHOT, AND SO THEY WOULDN'T BE
GOING TO PRISON UNLESS THEY
FAILED TREATMENT. AND THEN IF
THEY WENT TO PRISON, THEY COULD
RECEIVE SERVICES THERE, JUST
LIKE ANYBODY WHO GOES TO PRISON.
BUT THAT WOULDN'T BE PART OF THE
TREATMENT MANDATED FELONY. OKAY.
BUT THE ANALYSIS OF WHETHER OR
NOT A PERSON SHOULD GET
TREATMENT OR NOT OR BE IN THIS
PROGRAM WOULD BE AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL. IT WOULD BE DONE THROUGH
THE COURTS. SO THERE'S STATE AND
COUNTY ACTORS INVOLVED THERE, WE
DID ASSUME THAT MOST OF THE
SERVICE COSTS WOULD PROBABLY BE
AT A LOCAL LEVEL, GIVEN THE IT
SEEMS KIND OF A LOT OF THOSE
TYPES OF SERVICES RIGHT NOW. SO
THINKING ABOUT DRUG COURTS FOR
EXAMPLE, ARE OFTEN PROVIDED BY
LOCAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROBATION KIND OF COUNTY ACTORS.
RIGHT NOW, BUT THERE IS A STATE
COURT. THE STATE COURTS ARE ALSO
INVOLVED. OKAY. SO IF THIS WERE
TO GO AND BE, YOU KNOW, VOTED ON
BY THE LARGER PUBLIC, WHEN WOULD
WE KNOW SOME OF THE MORE FINER
DETAILS OF HOW THIS ACTUALLY IS
GOING TO WORK? I DON'T KNOW THAT
I HAVE A CLEAR ANSWER FOR YOU ON
THAT. OKAY. AND THEN DOLLAR
IMPLEMENTATION FOR THE COUNTY
VERSUS THE STATE, I'M SORRY, THE
DOLLAR IMPLEMENTATION FOR THE
COUNTY AND THE STATE IS NOT 100%
CLEAR EITHER, DO YOU MEAN LIKE
THE IMPLEMENTATION COSTS TO GET
IT? AND THEN THE MAINTENANCE,
OUR ESTIMATES ARE OF THE FULL
IMPLEMENTATION, ONGOING COSTS.
WE DIDN'T WE DON'T LOOK AT IF
THERE'S INITIAL START UP COSTS
OR KIND OF THINGS THAT ARE
HIGHLY SPECIFIC LIKE THAT. COULD
YOU STATE THE NUMBER OF THE COST
THAT YOU GUYS DO HAVE, SO WE
ESTIMATE THAT THE TOTAL INCREASE
IN LOCAL CRIMINAL JUSTICE COSTS
COULD BE IN THE TENS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ANNUALLY. OKAY. AND
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
WOULD BE LIKE ROUGHLY WHAT?
LET'S LET'S GIVE A LITTLE BIT
MORE OF A DEFINITIVE BALLPARK TO
US THAT MEANS ANYTHING IN THE
TENS OF MILLIONS. THAT IS THE
KIND OF RANGE OF UNCERTAINTY
THAT WE FELT WAS APPROPRIATE,
GIVEN THE UNCERTAINTIES. AND SO
WE WOULDN'T WANT TO CREATE
CERTAINTY WHERE IT DIDN'T EXIST.
OKAY AND WHERE WOULD THAT MONEY
COME FROM? THOSE ARE COUNTY
COSTS. SO THAT COULD WOULD COME
FROM WHATEVER REVENUE SOURCES
COUNTIES CHOOSE TO USE. OKAY. SO
THE COUNTY WOULD BE ON THE HOOK
FOR MOST OF THIS. THAT'S THAT IS
WHAT WE ESTIMATE. YEAH. ALL
RIGHT. I APPRECIATE IT. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS,
SENATOR, A FOLLOW UP TO THAT
WITH REGARD TO THE TREATMENT
MANDATED FELONIES THAT IS
ESSENTIALLY THE EQUIVALENT OF
WHAT USED TO BE DRUG COURT,
WHICH WAS PRETTY EXTENSIVELY
IMPLEMENTED, I BELIEVE, BEFORE
PROPOSITION 47. SO WE HAVE A
MODEL THAT WOULD INDICATE WHAT
COSTS WOULD BE FOR THIS BASED
UPON THAT EXPERIENCE BACK THEN.
CORRECT WE DID THINK ABOUT DRUG
COURTS AS A ONE POSSIBLE EXAMPLE
OF HOW THIS MIGHT LOOK, AS WE
WERE THINKING THROUGH WHAT SOME
OF THE FISCAL IMPLICATIONS MIGHT
BE. SO I THINK YOU KNOW, YES,
DRUG COURTS ARE ONE POSSIBILITY.
I THINK, YOU KNOW, THAT COULD BE
A QUESTION. MAYBE THAT'S MORE
APPROPRIATE FOR THE PROPONENTS
TO ASK THEM KIND OF WHAT THEY'RE
ENVISIONING. THE IMPLEMENTATION
WOULD LOOK LIKE, BECAUSE WE ARE
REALLY JUST GOING OFF OF THE
LANGUAGE THAT'S IN THE
PROPOSITION AND DOING OUR BEST
TO ESTIMATE WHAT WHAT COSTS
MIGHT LOOK LIKE BASED ON THAT.
BUT OF COURSE, THERE'S A LOT OF
DECISIONS THAT WOULD BE MADE IN
THE IMPLEMENTATION PROCESS THAT
WOULD ULTIMATELY AFFECT THE
DETAILS. AND THE COST. THANKS
THANK YOU, REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR, PRESENTATION. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT,
PRESENTERS. OUR NEXT PRESENTER
IS THE NAPA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY, ALLISON HALEY,
PRESIDENT, CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S ASSOCIATION. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. AND YOU HAVE UP
TO SEVEN MINUTES. AND I BELIEVE
YOU WERE TOLD THAT. YES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. I
WAS 14 YEARS OLD WHEN MY FATHER
WAS ARRESTED. HE WAS AN
ALCOHOLIC AND AN ADDICT. AND IT
TURNED OUT TO BE A PROLIFIC
THIEF AND EMBEZZLER. ASSET
FORFEITURE LEFT MY MOTHER AND ME
HOMELESS AND PENNILESS IN ORANGE
COUNTY, WHERE I GREW UP. HE DIED
IN 2005, POOR AND ADDICTED TO
PRESCRIPTION PILLS. MY LOVE FOR
HIM WAS AND REMAINS DEEP AND
WIDE AS ANYONE IN HERE KNOWS,
LOVING AN ADDICT IS A COMPLEX
AND MANY TIMES DEEPLY PAINFUL
JOY. MY DAD WAS CHARISMATIC,
SMART, VERY FUNNY, AND DEEPLY,
DEEPLY ILL. HIS CHOICES AND HIS
ADDICTIONS DESTROYED EVERY GOOD
THING AROUND HIM, INCLUDING
PARTS OF ME. MY NAME IS ALLISON
HALEY. I'M THE ELECTED DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OF NAPA COUNTY AND THE
NEWLY MINTED PRESIDENT OF CDAA.
I WENT INTO THIS PROFESSION
BECAUSE I THOUGHT THAT MY LIVED
EXPERIENCE COULD BRING BALANCE
TO THE OFFICE OF THE PROSECUTOR.
THE POWER OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM IS IMMENSE. I
KNOW THIS PERSONALLY. IT'S WHY
PROSECUTORS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
MUST BE BALANCED AND FAIR IN ITS
ENFORCEMENT. LAWS MUST BE
CAREFULLY DESIGNED TO ACHIEVE A
FAIR AND JUST GOAL TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC AND VICTIMS, AND HOLD
OFFENDERS PROPORTIONATELY
ACCOUNTABLE, ALL WHILE
MINIMIZING UNWANTED OR
UNWARRANTED COLLATERAL DAMAGE.
PROP 36 IS REASONED AND
THOUGHTFUL, DESIGNED TO NARROWLY
ADDRESS ISSUES THAT ARE REDUCING
THE QUALITY OF LIFE OF
CALIFORNIANS. THAT IS,
INCREASING HOMELESSNESS, RISING
RETAIL THEFT, AND A STARTLING
PROLIFERATION OF OPIOID RELATED
DEATHS. PROP 36 INCENTIVIZES
DRUG TREATMENT FOR ADDICTS BY
GIVING THEM CHOICES, BY GIVING
THEM DETERMINATIVE AGENCY IN
THEIR OWN LIVES, THEY CAN
AFFIRMATIVELY CHOOSE TO ENTER
INTO DRUG TREATMENT AND MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT. THEY CAN
CHOOSE TO NOT GO INTO CUSTODY.
THEY CAN CHOOSE A SUITE OF
SERVICES, ALL AIMED TO GIVE THEM
HOPE AND A LIFE AND A FUTURE. IT
ALLOWS PROSECUTORS TO TREAT AN
OFFENDER WITH A SINGLE THEFT
DIFFERENTLY THAN SOMEONE WHO IS
A SERIAL OFFENDER. IT ALLOWS US
TO AGGREGATE THEFTS SO THAT THE
PENALTY, ULTIMATELY OVERSEEN BY
A JUDGE, IS COMMENSURATE WITH
THE AMOUNT OF HARM SUFFERED BY
BUSINESSES IN OUR COMMUNITIES,
AND IT ALLOWS PROSECUTORS TO
TREAT FENTANYL LIKE THE SCOURGE
THAT IT IS. CALIFORNIA COULDN'T
SIGN. CALIFORNIANS FORGIVE ME,
COULDN'T SIGN THE PETITIONS TO
PUT THIS ON THE BALLOT FAST
ENOUGH. CONDITIONS IN THIS STATE
HAVE BECOME, FOR MANY,
INTOLERABLE. THE SUPPORT HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
IMPORTANTLY, PROP 36, IF PASSED,
IS STILL SUBJECT TO THE
DISCRETION OF ELECTED DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS AND APPOINTED SUPERIOR
COURT JUDGES ACROSS THE STATE.
CALIFORNIANS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
EXPECT THAT DA'S ARE SMART AND
SURGICAL IN HOW THEY WILL APPLY
THE CHANGES AND ALWAYS MINDFUL
OF THE FACTS OF INDIVIDUAL CASE.
I AM NOT A DISTRICT ATTORNEY
FROM THE 1980S. I AM A DISTRICT
ATTORNEY WHO WAS DEEPLY WOUNDED
BY THE POLICIES ENACTED AT THAT
TIME. MY FATHER'S INCARCERATION
CHANGED THE VERY TRAJECTORY OF
MY LIFE, AND IN MANY WAYS, IT
WAS THE MOST NEGATIVE THING THAT
HAS EVER HAPPENED TO ME. I AM
NOT A DA WHO BELIEVES IN
MINDLESSLY FILLING UP PRISONS,
BUT I'M ALSO NOT A DA WHO
APOLOGIZES FOR SEEKING
RESOLUTIONS THAT ARE
COMMENSURATE WITH THE HARM
SUFFERED BY VICTIMS OR
COMMUNITIES, AND OUR STATE IS
SUFFERING, AND IT'S TIME TO
OFFER SOME REFORM. I APPRECIATE
VERY MUCH YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION THIS MORNING. THANK
YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, SENATOR NIELLO, THANK
YOU, YOU HAVE QUITE A COMPELLING
PERSONAL STORY TO GO ALONG WITH
YOUR CHOICE OF PROFESSION, AND I
FIND THAT TO BE ADMIRABLY
BALANCED, SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY
OF YOUR FATHER AND THE TROUBLES
THAT THAT HE HAD, I WAS ASKING
THE LAO ABOUT THE, TREATMENT
MANDATED FELONY, AND IT THE THAT
IN ITS RELATIONSHIP WITH WHAT
USED TO BE DRUG COURT, GIVEN
YOUR EXPERIENCE, HOW DO YOU
ASSESS THAT PIECE OF PROPOSITION
36 AND ITS, POTENTIAL
EFFECTIVENESS IN DEALING WITH
DRUG ADDICTION IN OUR STREETS? I
BELIEVE THAT THE DRUG, THE
DISEASE OF DRUG ADDICTION, ROBS
PEOPLE OF THE ABILITY TO MAKE
DECISIONS IN THEIR OWN BEST
INTEREST. MY DAD WOULD ALWAYS
PICK DRUGS OR ALCOHOL, ALWAYS.
AND IT'S NOT THAT HE DIDN'T LOVE
ME. HE DID. BUT I WOULD ALWAYS
COME SECOND UNTIL DRUG TREATMENT
IS MADE COMPULSORY. I DON'T
THINK HE WOULD HAVE EVER CHOSEN
IT FOR HIMSELF. MY DAD WENT IN
AND OUT OF SOBRIETY THROUGH THE
COURSE OF MY LIFE, AND THE ONLY
TIME THAT IT EVER STUCK, OR THE
ONLY TIME THAT HE WILLINGLY WENT
INTO, TREATMENT PROGRAMS, WAS
AFTER THERE HAD BEEN OTHER KINDS
OF INTERVENTIONS THAT MADE IT
COMPULSORY. IF HE HAD THE CHOICE
TO GO TO JAIL AND GET
IMMEDIATELY RELEASED TO USE
DRUGS, HE MIGHT NOT HAVE ALWAYS
TAKEN IT. THANK YOU, CHAIR.
BRADFORD. YES, SENATOR BRADFORD,
THANK YOU. I WAS JUST CURIOUS
WHAT OUR PROPOSITION 36 CUT
FUNDING TO SOME OF THE PROVEN
TREATMENT PROGRAMS. AND OTHER
VICTIM SERVICES THAT EXISTS,
RIGHT NOW. THERE'S ALWAYS A
PRIORITY LIST FOR THE NEEDS OF
SOCIETY AND PRIORITIZING MENTAL
HEALTH AND INCENTIVIZING DRUG
TREATMENT ARE PRIORITIES THAT
MOST CALIFORNIANS AGREE WOULD BE
PARAMOUNT. I CAN'T SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT WHAT THINGS
WOULD BE CUT, BUT I DO THINK
THAT THERE IS MONEY THAT IS
GOING TO BE EARMARKED FOR MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT AND FOR DRUG
ADDICTION TREATMENT, AND I THINK
THAT THAT'S VALUABLE. CHAIR.
THANK YOU. DA, THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION. AND AS
SENATOR NILO SAID, FOR SHARING
YOUR COMPELLING STORY, I'VE
NEVER HEARD THAT BEFORE. SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PUBLIC
SERVICE. I WANTED TO GIVE YOU
THE CHANCE TO ADDRESS A COUPLE
OF THE ISSUES THAT WILL THAT
WE'LL HEAR FROM, SOME OF THE
OPPONENTS IN A LITTLE BIT. AND
I'LL CONVERSELY ASK THEM THE
SAME, THE SAME TYPE OF
QUESTIONING. SO ONE, WE HEAR AS
FAR AS THE PETTY THEFT WITH A
PRIOR, WHICH I BELIEVE WAS A
SHORTCOMING IN OUR LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE, WE DEAL HEAVILY ON, THE
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT, BUT THE
PETTY THEFT WITH A PRIOR, I
DON'T THINK IS ADEQUATELY
ADDRESSED UNLESS WE GO BACK TO
THE VOTERS, WHICH WE'RE DOING.
SO I, I THINK THAT THIS IS THE
RIGHT APPROACH. AND I THINK
IT'S, YOU KNOW, I TALKED TO
DOZENS OF SMALL BUSINESSES AND,
YOU KNOW, THEY'RE NOT THE BIG
SMASH AND GRABS ARE NOT PUBLICLY
OWNED COMPANIES TRADED
COMPANIES. THEY'RE SMALL
BUSINESSES. AND DEATH BY A
THOUSAND CUTS. AND I'VE HEARD
THEIR STORIES LOUD AND CLEAR,
WITH THAT, I DID WANT TO ASK,
YOU KNOW, HYPOTHETICAL AND
QUESTION. WE'VE HEARD OVER AND
OVER THAT INDIVIDUALS WITH WITH
TWO OR MORE PRIORS, IF SOMEBODY
GOES IN THERE AND, YOU KNOW,
STEALS A 12 PACK OF BUD LIGHT,
IS THAT IS THAT WORTH HAVING
MULTIPLE YEARS SENTENCED IN A
STATE PRISON AND WHAT WHAT KIND
OF HYPOTHETICAL SITUATION WOULD
YOU ADDRESS TO THIS? WELL
SCENARIO, I THINK THAT THIS IS
WHERE PROSECUTORIAL DISCRETION
BECOMES IMPORTANT. IF YOU PUT
THAT SCENARIO IN FRONT OF ME.
NO, THAT WOULD NOT BE SOMETHING
THAT I WOULD BE CHARGING WITH A
FELONY POTENTIALLY. BUT IT IS
POSSIBLE UNDER PROP 36, I THINK
THAT I THINK THAT THE WHAT'S
REALLY MISSING SOMETIMES IN THE
ANALYSIS OF PROP 36 OR WHAT IS
IGNORED, IS THE FACT THAT IT IS
ALWAYS SUBJECT TO THE DISCRETION
OF THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY, WHO
CAN CHOOSE TO CHARGE AS A FELONY
OR CHOOSE TO KEEP IT AS A
MISDEMEANOR. AND ALSO THE
OVERSIGHT OF THE SUPERIOR COURT
APPOINTED, OF COURSE, TO ENSURE
THAT THE ULTIMATE PUNISHMENT IS
COMMENSURATE WITH THE HARM
CAUSED TO THE COMMUNITY. OKAY.
THANK YOU. QUESTION NUMBER TWO.
WHAT ABOUT THIS SO-CALLED ISSUE
WITH A WASHOUT PERIOD? SO, YOU
KNOW, I'M 52 YEAR OLD MAN. I DID
A BUNCH OF STUPID STUFF WHEN I
WAS A TEENAGER. AND LUCKILY WE
HAVE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS AND
WE DON'T HAVE LOTS OF EVIDENCE
ON THAT. SO LET'S CONSIDER A
HYPOTHETICAL OF SOMEBODY WHO HAD
SOME ARREST WHEN THEY WERE LATE
TEENS, EARLY 20S AND THAT'S, YOU
KNOW, 30 PLUS YEARS AGO. AND
THEN THEY GET ARRESTED FOR THE
12 OR WHAT HAVE YOU ANY, ANY
THIRD OFFENSE. SO HOW WOULD YOU,
AS THE DA IN NAPA COUNTY. AND
GRANTED YOU'RE ONE OF, YOU KNOW,
50 PLUS COUNTIES AND 58 COUNTIES
IN CALIFORNIA, HOW WOULD HOW
WOULD YOU EQUATE THAT WITH THIS
WHOLE NOTION THAT IT COULD BE
OVER MULTIPLE YEARS OR EVEN
MULTIPLE DECADES? BECAUSE IN MY
VIEW, REPEAT IS REPETITIVE, LIKE
LIKE HAPPENING IN A, IN A TIME
CERTAIN PERIOD, NOT POTENTIALLY
OVER. WELL, I WOULD WANT TO
KNOW, HOW CRAZY WERE YOU WHEN
YOU WERE A KID, I'D WANT TO KNOW
THE SERIOUSNESS OF THOSE PRIOR
EVENTS. I'D WANT TO KNOW THE
RECENCY OF WHAT YOU HAVE HAVE,
HAVE SPOKEN ABOUT. AND I WANT TO
KNOW WHETHER OR NOT THERE WERE
VICTIMS AT THE TIME. BUT IF
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A BUNCH OF
PETTY THEFTS IN SOMEONE'S
HISTORY FROM THE 1980S OR 1990S,
AND THEN SUDDENLY WE HAVE A NEW
INCIDENT. I HAVE CLIENTS, THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, AND I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT MOVING FORWARD WITH A
FELONY IN THOSE KINDS OF
SITUATIONS IS WHAT IT IS THAT
THEY'RE ASKING ME TO DO. I THINK
THAT YOU'VE HIT IT, THAT THIS IS
REALLY DESIGNED, AND PARTS OF IT
ARE DESIGNED FOR THOSE KINDS OF
SERIAL OFFENDERS THAT CALIFORNIA
IS SEEING. AND AGAIN, IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR PROSECUTORS
ELECTED BY THE CONSTITUENCIES TO
SHOW THAT REASONED AND MEASURED
DISCRETION IN APPLICATION. YEAH.
AND I GUESS THAT, YOU KNOW, I
THINK THAT'S AN APPROPRIATE
ANSWER. AND I'M CONFIDENT THAT
MY DA HERE IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY,
TI¾N HÌ WOULD HAVE A SIMILAR
ANSWER. BUT HOW DO WE KNOW THE
DA IN INYO COUNTY OR WHATEVER
COUNTY IS GOING TO HAVE THAT
SAME PERSPECTIVE? AND THIS IS A
STATEWIDE POLICY. SO HOW WOULD
YOU ADDRESS THAT? AND THAT'S
GOING TO BE THE QUESTION FOR THE
CITIZENS OF THAT PARTICULAR
COUNTY. OKAY. THANK YOU. AND
LAST LASTLY, CAN YOU, YOU KNOW,
THE LA EARLIER TALKED ABOUT THE
IMPACT COULD BE IN THE A WIDE
RANGE IN THE TENS OF MILLIONS TO
THE LOW HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS IN
COMBINED. COUNTY, COUNTY, COUNTY
JAIL COSTS AND POTENTIAL STATE
PRISON COSTS, WHAT DO YOU THINK
THE IMPACT WILL BE TO OUR TO OUR
STATE CORRECTIONAL SYSTEMS,
WHETHER STATE CORRECTIONAL
SYSTEMS AND OUR COUNTY JAILS? I
THINK IT WILL BE SIGNIFICANT. I
DO THINK THAT A NUMBER OF THE,
THE KIND OF DAMAGE THAT WE'RE
SEEING IS HAPPENING FROM A
RELATIVELY SMALLER NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS. SO IT MAY BE THAT
THOSE NUMBERS ARE INFLATED, BUT
I DO THINK THAT THERE EXISTS
ALREADY CERTAINLY IN NAPA COUNTY,
ALREADY IN PLACE IN OUR COUNTY,
ARE OPPORTUNITIES TO RECEIVE
DRUG TREATMENT, MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT AND SO FORTH THAT WE
CAN LEVERAGE WHEN IT'S WHEN AND
IF IT GETS PASSED IN NOVEMBER.
BUT THESE AREN'T PEOPLE TO THROW
AWAY, AND I CAN'T THINK OF A
MORE HONORABLE PLACE FOR US TO
USE OUR MONEY THAN TO HELP
PEOPLE BECOME HEALTHIER IN ALL
WAYS. THANK YOU. SO I DO HAVE A
QUESTION. I THINK THAT SOME OF
MY COLLEAGUES BROUGHT THIS UP IS
THAT, SO IN REGARDS TO
AGGREGATION, THERE IS NO
LOOKBACK PERIOD. CORRECT. IT
COULD GO BACK 20 YEARS, 30
YEARS, 40 YEARS. THAT IS WHAT I
UNDERSTAND. OKAY. AND THEN AS
FAR AS THE FENTANYL ADVISEMENT,
YOU KNOW, IT APPLIES TO A HARD
DRUG CONVICTIONS. YOU KNOW, I
THINK IT STATES THAT FOR ANY
SCHEDULED ONE AND SCHEDULED TWO
DRUGS IN PARTICULAR, BUT DOES IT
EXEMPT APPLICATION TO MINORS?
ARE YOU SAYING THAT WE WOULDN'T
GIVE THAT TO A MINOR. SO IN THE
EVENT THAT WE WERE TO HAVE A
DRUG TRAFFICKER WHO WAS A MINOR,
WHO WAS SELLING FENTANYL. SO
CURRENTLY THE WAY IT'S WRITTEN,
IT DOES NOT HAVE ANY LANGUAGE
THAT EXEMPTS THIS APPLICATION TO
MINORS. COULD YOU ELABORATE AS
TO WHAT IS THE THOUGHT PROCESS
OF THAT? NOTHING ABOUT THAT.
WELL, I THINK THAT PROVIDING
NOTICE TO DEFENDANTS OR MINORS
DOES NOT NECESSARILY FOLLOW
THAT. IN THE EVENT THAT WE ARE
TO HAVE A LATER INCIDENT WHERE
THERE WAS SALES AND A SUBSEQUENT
DEATH, IT DOESN'T TIE THE HANDS
OF A PROSECUTOR TO THEREFORE
ABSOLUTELY SEEK THE IMPLIED
MALICE MURDER, MEANING THAT EVEN
IF I HAD A CASE WHERE I HAD
SALES AND THERE HAD BEEN A
DEATH, AND I FIND OUT THAT THAT
THAT WARNING HAD BEEN GIVEN WHEN
THAT MINOR WAS A 16 YEAR OLD, OR
A 17 YEAR OLD, OR A 14 YEAR OLD,
THERE IS NOTHING ABOUT PROVIDING
THE PROVISION FOR GIVING SOMEONE
NOTICE ABOUT THE SERIOUSNESS OF
THE OFFENSE. THAT TIES THE HANDS
OF THE PROSECUTOR AND MAKES A
SECOND DEGREE MURDER CHARGE
NECESSARY LATER IN THE FUTURE.
OKAY, BUT THERE IS NOTHING THAT
PROTECTS A MINOR CURRENTLY IN
THE CURRENT STATUTE THAT IS
PROPOSED, CORRECT? CERTAINLY,
THE PROTECTION OF THE
PROSECUTORIAL DISCRETION AND THE
OVERSIGHT OF A SUPERIOR COURT
JUDGE. OKAY. AND THEN WITH 58
DIFFERENT COUNTIES AND 58
DIFFERENT DA'S, OBVIOUSLY THAT
WOULD BE VERY DIFFERENT. I
REPRESENT TWO COUNTIES. THE DA'S
ARE VERY DIFFERENT FROM EACH
OTHER. RIGHT. SO THERE'S NOTHING
IN LANGUAGE RIGHT NOW IN THIS
PROPOSAL THAT LEGITIMATELY AND
CLEARLY STATES ANY PROTECTION
FOR A MINOR. I JUST WANT A YES
OR NO. THERE IS NOTHING THAT
SAYS THAT WE CANNOT PROVIDE
NOTICE TO A MINOR. OKAY, SO
THAT'S ENOUGH. THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE HAVE QUESTIONS?
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IF I COULD JUST
FOLLOW UP ON THAT, ISN'T IT TRUE
THAT IN JUVENILE COURT, THOUGH,
THAT THEY'RE NEVER CONVICTED
UNLESS IT'S A CRIME AS SERIOUS
AS MURDER THEY'RE ADJUDICATED,
BUT IN A DRUG COURT AND IN A
DRUG OFFENSE. RIGHT. THEY'RE NOT
CONVICTED. YES, SIR. THANK YOU.
BUT IF IT'S IN REGARDS TO MURDER
AND POTENTIALLY WITH AN
OVERDOSE, IT WOULD POTENTIALLY
BE ON THE TABLE, CORRECT. SO IN
THAT SCENARIO, WE HAVE A
JUVENILE WHO'S CONVICTED OF A
FENTANYL RELATED MURDER. AND
YOU'RE ASKING WHETHER THAT'S A
CONVICTION OR AN ADJUDICATION
POTENTIALLY WHERE AGAIN THE
MINOR IS NOT NECESSARILY
PROTECTED. IF A 16 YEAR OLD IS
SELLING DRUGS. RIGHT, AND I
THINK IT WAS REFERENCED AND I
THINK THAT EVEN TO YOUR STORY
OF, YOU KNOW, WHETHER YOUTH
FULLY UNDERSTANDS WHAT THEY ARE
DOING, THE DEPTH OF THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THEIR ACTIONS,
AND SOMEBODY DOES DIE IN THIS
TRANSACTION, WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
MINOR? OH, WELL, THAT'S A THAT'S
A QUESTION FAR BEYOND THE SCOPE
OF PROP 36. SO PROP 36 IS ONLY
DISCUSSING THAT SORT OF WATSON
LIKE MURDER ADVISEMENT. NOT ON
THE ADJUDICATION OF MURDERS OR
FENTANYL RELATED INCIDENTS AS
MINORS. SO IF SOMEBODY AGAIN,
THERE IS NO EXEMPTION CLEARLY IN
THE LANGUAGE REGARDING MINORS,
THOUGH, THERE IS NO EXEMPTION
ABOUT PROVIDING NOTICE TO
MINORS, CORRECT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE OUR NEXT
PRESENTER, SACRAMENTO COUNTY
SHERIFF JIM COOPER. GOOD
MORNING. CHAIRS AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. GREAT TO BE HERE, PROP
47 IS CLEAR. NO MEANINGFUL
CHANGES CAN FIX 47 UNLESS IT
GOES BACK TO THE VOTERS. WHILE
THE RECENTLY PASSED LEGISLATIVE
BILL PACKAGE HAS AGGREGATION IN
IT, AGGREGATION HAS ALREADY BEEN
TESTED BY THE STATE COURTS AND
REJECTED THE OTHER LEGISLATIVE
ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS PROP 47
ISSUES WITH A BYPASS BILL. ORSI
HAS PROVED TO BE ALMOST USELESS
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT. PROP 36
DOES NOT HAVE THIS PROBLEM
BECAUSE IT WILL BE DECIDED BY
THE VOTERS. PROP 36 IS
STRAIGHTFORWARD. HERE ARE THE
FACTS. THE OPPONENTS WILL ARGUE
THAT PROPOSITION IS UNNECESSARY
SINCE REPORTED THEFT IS DONE IS
DOWN. THAT IS SIMPLY NOT TRUE.
IT IS UNDERREPORTED SINCE THE
PENALTY IS A MERE MISDEMEANOR,
THE SAME AS BREAKING A WINDOW OR
SPRAY PAINTING GRAFFITI. HERE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY, WE'VE HAD 15
ORC OPERATIONS RANGING FROM 1 TO
7 DAYS. THE OPERATIONS FOCUSED
ON MORE THAN 70 STORES. WHAT WE
FOUND WERE THAT MORE THAN 1000
ARRESTS AND CITATIONS, 75% WERE
MISDEMEANOR ARRESTS, 80% WERE
REPEAT OFFENDERS FOR THEFT, 15%
OF THE OFFENDERS WERE HOMELESS,
AND LESS THAN 10% WERE FOOD
RELATED ITEMS. WE HAVE EXPENDED
THE FUNDS FOR THESE ORC
OPERATIONS. I DO NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO GO AFTER EVERY
MISDEMEANOR OFFENDER. IN
ADDITION, I HAVE NO AUTHORITY
OVER WHETHER THE DA DECIDES TO
PROSECUTE AN OFFENDER. THE
OPPONENTS ARE CLAIMING ALL
OFFENDERS WILL NOW GO TO PRISON,
WHICH IS A LIE. YOU GO TO PRISON
UNDER PROP 36, BUT ONLY IF YOU
ARE CONVICTED OF USING A GUN
WHILE YOU'RE DEALING FENTANYL.
HAVING ENOUGH FENTANYL AS A
DEALER TO KILL THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE OR HAVE AT LEAST FOUR
FELONIES OR CONVICTIONS FOR
FELONY RETAIL THEFT, EVEN PRISON
ELIGIBLE CRIMES FOR REPEATED
RETAIL THEFTS OR WOBBLERS. I
WANT TO SAY THAT AGAIN, WOBBLERS
THE COURTS HAVE THE JURISDICTION
OVER JAIL VERSUS PRISON. ANOTHER
KEY ELEMENT OF PROP 36 IS COURT
ORDERED, MANDATED DRUG TREATMENT
DIVERSION. WHEN PROP 47 PASSED,
IT ELIMINATED DRUG TREATMENT
DIVERSION. THIS RESULTED IN A
70%. I'LL SAY IT AGAIN, 70% DROP
IN PARTICIPATION OF MANDATED
DRUG COURT TREATMENT IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY. THAT MEANT
THAT ALL THESE OFFENDERS WHO
COULD HAVE GONE THROUGH A DRUG
TREATMENT PROGRAM AND GOTTEN
THEIR LIVES BACK AND HAD THEIR
RECORDS CLEARED, LOST THAT
OPTION, PROP 36 FIXES THIS AND
HELPS THOSE WHO NEED HELP WITH
DRUG ADDICTION GET HELP AND
ACTUALLY RECLAIM THEIR LIVES. AS
FOR FENTANYL, THE NUMBER OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY DEATHS RELATED
TO FENTANYL INCREASED MORE THAN
TENFOLD FROM 2019 THROUGH 2023,
ACCORDING TO THE LATEST DATA
FROM THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY
CORONER'S OFFICE. IN THE LAST
YEAR, THERE'S AT LEAST ONE
FENTANYL DEATH EVERY DAY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY, AND THAT'S
SUBSTANTIALLY UNDERREPORTED.
SACRAMENTO HAD MORE THAN 400
FENTANYL DEATHS IN 2023, UP 33
FROM 2019. IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY,
IN JUST SEVEN FENTANYL BUSTS,
OFFICERS RETRIEVED 43 GUNS. THEY
ALSO SEIZED 147 POUNDS OF
FENTANYL. THAT IS ENOUGH
FENTANYL TO KILL THE ENTIRE CITY
OF ELK GROVE, WHICH IS THE
SECOND BIGGEST CITY IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY. LET'S GET THE
FACTS RIGHT. PROP 36 DOES NOT
CREATE MASS INCARCERATION, BUT
RATHER PUTS PEOPLE THAT NEED TO
BE IN JAIL, IN JAIL, AND PUTS IN
PRISON. CRIMINALS WHO PUT
CALIFORNIANS LIVES IN DANGER.
ADDICTION IS RAVAGING MY
COMMUNITY. PROP 36 PROVIDES AN
AVENUE FOR THOSE ADDICTED A WAY
OUT OF THE CYCLE OF ABUSE. THIS
IS NOT A WAR ON DRUGS. IT'S A
WAR ON ADDICTION. YOU THINK
ABOUT PROP 47, WHICH IS ENACTED
BY THE VOTERS IN 2014. EVERY
YEAR, MULTIPLE BILLS HAVE TRIED
TO BE PUT THROUGH THIS BODY TO
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES. AND
SHORTCOMINGS. THEY NEVER SAW THE
LIGHT OF DAY. THIS YEAR, 13
BILLS WENT THROUGH. I ASKED YOU,
WHY DID 13 BILLS GO THROUGH?
BECAUSE IT'S SO BAD. I WAS HERE
FOR EIGHT YEARS, FROM 2014 TO
2022. IN THE SAME BUILDING, AND
I SAW THE LAWS THAT WERE PASSED.
NOW, BEING SHERIFF, I SEE THE
IMPACT OF THOSE LAWS. IT IS IT
IS AN ISSUE. WE DON'T WANT TO
SEND EVERYBODY TO JAIL. BUT WITH
THE DRUG ADDICTION, YOU HAVE TO
HAVE THE CARROT AND THE STICK.
THE COURTS DO THAT. YOU'VE GOT
TO FORCE THEM INTO TREATMENT.
OUR HOMELESS ISSUES REVOLVE
AROUND THIS TOO. WE DON'T WANT
TO DO THAT. WE DON'T WANT TO BE
THE ADULT IN THE ROOM AND SAY,
HEY, YOU NEED TO GET HELP. THIS
DOES IT. AND THAT'S THE ISSUE.
WE HAVE TO DO IT. AND IT'S COME
TO THIS AND I KEEP GOING BACK TO
WHY WERE ALL THESE BILLS PASSED
THIS YEAR? BECAUSE IT'S SO BAD.
THAT'S WHY. AND WE'VE GOT TO
CHANGE IT. THE PUBLIC'S MAD. I
HEAR THEM EVERY DAY. I SEE THEM
WHEN I'M OUT THERE. THEY WANT US
TO CHANGE IT AND THAT'S WHY
WE'RE HERE. IT COULD HAVE BEEN
DONE A LONG TIME AGO, BUT THE
OPPONENTS DIDN'T WANT ANYTHING
DONE AND IT'S GOTTEN OUT OF
CONTROL. SO I THINK IT'S A GREAT
THING. I THINK THE JUDGES HAVE
INFLUENCE. EVERYONE'S NOT GOING
TO JAIL ON THIS. THE COURT HAS
DISCRETION. THE DA'S HAVE
DISCRETION. AND THAT'S WHY IT'S
A WOBBLER. SO IF SOMEONE A SIX
PACK OF BEER, ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S
MCCARTY STATED, CAN DO THAT, THE
JUDGE HAS A DISCRETION. THE DA
HAS DISCRETION. SO WE'RE NOT
FORCING PEOPLE IN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY MEMBER. LACKEY
YEAH. PART PART OF THE
FRUSTRATION, I THINK, THAT THE
PUBLIC FEELS IS THAT THERE'S
REALLY VERY LITTLE
ACCOUNTABILITY WITH THEFT. AND
SO WHAT EFFECT WILL WOULD THE
PASSAGE OF PROP 46 HAVE ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ABILITY TO
ARREST SHOPLIFTERS AND THIEVES?
WOULD THEY EVER BE ARRESTED AND
BOOKED? YEAH, AND IT'LL HELP US
REALLY THE MOST PROLIFIC ONES.
AND I THINK IT'S NOT EVERYONE
YOU DO HAVE PROLIFIC FOLKS THAT
KNOW THERE'S NO ACCOUNTABILITY.
I'M NOT GOING TO GET IN TROUBLE.
WE'VE GOT FOLKS WALKING OUT WITH
BIG SCREEN TVS, BRINGING THEIR
KIDS OUT TO SHOP WITH THEM AND
PUSHING IT. SO IN SOME OF THESE
INSTANCES, IT IS THE SAME GROUP
OF PEOPLE THAT KNOW I'M NOT
GOING TO GET IN TROUBLE. SO I'M
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND DO THIS.
AND I THINK IT SENDS A MESSAGE.
AND SOME OF THESE ORC OPERATIONS
WHICH THE LEGISLATURE FUNDED.
THANK YOU. WE'VE SEEN A DECREASE
IN THAT BECAUSE THEY KNOW WE'RE
OUT THERE ENFORCING THE LAWS.
AND THAT'S REALLY BEEN THE BIG
ISSUE. THEY KNOW THERE'S TEETH
TO IT. SO I THINK WE'RE IN A
GOOD POSITION. AND PROP 36
HELPS. AND I KEEP COMING BACK.
WE HAVE TO REALIZE ALL THE BILLS
THIS YEAR AND THE PUBLIC IS
ANGRY. THEY WANT SOMETHING DONE.
THEY'RE TIRED OF WALKING IN
THERE AND PUSHING THE BUTTON
BECAUSE THE DEODORANT AND SOAP
IS LOCKED BEHIND PLEXIGLASS.
THAT'S THE BIG ISSUE WITH THEM.
THEY WANT IT CHANGED AND I THINK
WE HAVE A CHANCE TO DO THAT. AND
FINALLY, THIS HAS TO DO WITH OUR
PREVIOUS CONVERSATION WHEN WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT MINORS. ISN'T
IT PRETTY MUCH TRUE THAT MINORS
CANNOT GO TO PRISON? CORRECT.
MINORS DON'T GO TO PRISON?
THAT'S ALL I WANTED TO CLARIFY.
DJ WAS CLOSED. THERE IS NO
PRISON FOR MINORS. THEY SPEND
THEIR TIME IN JUVENILE HALL.
THANK YOU. OKAY, I JUST WANT TO
FOLLOW UP. THERE IS JUVENILE
HALL, CORRECT? JUVENILE HALL?
YES YES, ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I
DO HAVE FOR YOU AND I DO BELIEVE
THAT MORE TREATMENT OPTIONS ARE
NEEDED, ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE
THAT HAVE, SUFFERED FROM
ADDICTION. THE QUESTION I HAVE,
THOUGH, IS THAT A LOT OF
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES CLEARLY
SHOW THAT IF A PERSON IS AN
ADDICT, THAT THE BEST SUCCESS
FOR THEM TO STAY CLEAN IS TO
SELF-SELECT, TO GO TO TREATMENT.
CORRECT? I DON'T THINK SO,
SENATOR. AND THE REASON I SAY
THAT, AND HOW YOU'VE DONE FOR
THE PAST TWO YEARS WITH THE
HOMELESS, WE'VE OFFERED THOSE
SERVICES TO A LOT OF PEOPLE,
SELF-SELECT. THEY DON'T
SELF-SELECT THE SAME THING FOR
HOUSING. THEY DON'T SELF-SELECT
BECAUSE DRUGS ARE SO POWERFUL
AND IT'S HARD TO GET OVER DRUGS
ADDICTION, LET ALONE ALCOHOL.
AND THAT'S WHERE THE FORCED
TREATMENT HAS TO COME INTO PLAY.
AND I THINK I AGREE WITH YOU.
TREATMENT IS THE BEST OPTION. IT
IS. IT IS A ILLNESS, BUT IT HAS
TO BE TREATED WITH A LITTLE BIT
OF FORCE AND TO MANDATE AND
FORCE THEM IN THERE. IF YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO FORCE THEM IN
THERE, IT OFFERS NO HOPE BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO DO IT
THEMSELVES, HAVE INTERVENTIONS.
SO THERE'S NO FAMILY TO
INTERVENE FOR THESE FOLKS. IT'S
LEFT UP TO US TO INTERVENE. AND
TO ME, THE BEST WAY IS THROUGH
THE COURTS. A NEUTRAL THIRD
PARTY, NOT LAW ENFORCEMENT, NOT
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S, TO MAKE
THEM GO AND GET THE HELP THEY
NEED. SO I AGREE WITH YOU 100%.
WE'VE GOT TO FIX IT. BUT UP
UNTIL NOW, NO ONE'S WANTED TO DO
THAT. NO ONE'S WANTED TO CHANGE
IT. IT'S BEEN STATUS QUO. AND
THAT'S WHAT'S REALLY, HURT US,
SO, YOU KNOW, I PERSONALLY DO
AGREE WITH TREATMENT, AND I
THINK I'VE SHARED THIS. YOU
KNOW, WE'VE EVEN PASSED
LEGISLATION THAT, OUR CHAIR HERE
HAS IMPLEMENTED AS EVEN TRIAL
PROGRAMS IN THE REGION TO KIND
OF FORCE AND PERSUADE PEOPLE TO
GO INTO TREATMENT, BUT
SPECIFICALLY THE FACT THAT IT'S
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES AND
CLEARLY SHOWS THAT THERE IS DATA
THAT SHOWS THE BEST SUCCESS OF
KEEPING SOMEBODY CLEAN IS, OF
COURSE, THEIR WILLINGNESS TO
ENTER THESE TYPES OF PROGRAMS.
RIGHT, AND, AND I WANT TO BASE
SOME OF OUR COMMENTARY NOT ON
THE EMOTIONAL ASPECT OF IT,
BECAUSE I PERSONALLY AGREE WITH
YOU IN THE SENSE OF THERE DOES
NEED TO BE A CARROT AND STICK.
RIGHT? AND WE DO NEED RULE OF
LAW AND SO, SO MUCH MORE. BUT
THE CONCERN THAT I HAVE IS THAT,
IS THIS NOT GOING TO NECESSARILY
JUST BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
SOMEBODY WHO, YOU KNOW, GETS
PICKED UP AND DECIDES TO GO INTO
THIS TYPE OF TREATMENT AND THEN
GETS BACK OUT AND THEN CONTINUES
TO BE AN ADDICT AND COMMIT CRIME
AND MUCH MORE BECAUSE OF THE
FACT THAT IT IS NOT BASED.
NOTHING IN THIS IS BASED VÀ
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICE, THROUGH
TREATMENT AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
I THINK YOUR KEY WORD IS
WILLINGNESS AND THE WILLINGNESS.
AND THAT'S WHY THE FAMILY
INTERVENTIONS AND SOME FOLKS
THAT HAVE FAMILY SUPPORT, THEY
MIGHT GO THROUGH REHAB, REHAB, 2
OR 3 TIMES. IT IS TOUGH. I
WORKED IN NARCOTICS FOR FIVE
YEARS UNDERCOVER. IT IS HARD TO
GET OFF DOPE AND EVEN ALCOHOL.
AND THAT'S THE THING. AND IT'S
THE WILLINGNESS AND A LOT OF
THESE FOLKS WE'VE SEEN AND I'VE
SEEN PERSONALLY FIRSTHAND IN
DEALING WITH THE HOMELESS AND
SOME OF THESE OTHER FOLKS, THEY
JUST DON'T HAVE THE WILL,
WHATEVER IT IS, MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES OR DRUG THINGS TO DO IT
THEMSELVES. AND THEY NEED THAT
TO STICK FROM THE COURTS TO DO
THAT. AND THAT'S THE ISSUE. THE
WHEREWITHAL HASN'T BEEN THERE,
AND WE'VE SEEN THAT ON THE
HOMELESS FRONT, WITH EVERYTHING
THAT'S BEEN SPENT THERE AND WITH
THESE DRUG ADDICTS, WITH
FENTANYL, THE DEATHS I MEAN, IN
MY JAIL RIGHT NOW, SENATOR, I'VE
HAD INMATE DEATHS OVER FENTANYL
BECAUSE THEY SMUGGLE DRUGS IN
AND THEY KNOW FENTANYL WILL KILL
THEM, BUT THEY STILL WANT TO GET
THAT DRUG IN THEIR SYSTEM. AND
THAT'S PEOPLE CAN'T THE NORMAL
PUBLIC CAN'T RATIONALIZE THAT.
HOW DO THEY BRING THE DRUGS INTO
THESE FACILITIES? SO INMATES
THAT ARE GOING TO BE TURN
THEMSELVES IN WILL SECRETE DRUGS
IN THEIR RECTUM, BRING IT IN AND
PASS IT OUT AND GIVE IT TO
INMATES. WE HAVE INMATES
FAMILIES THAT ARE FACILITATING
CASH APPS, PAYING DEALERS THAT
HAVE BOUGHT IT IN. I HAVE PHONE
CALLS, RECORDED PHONE CALLS
WHERE THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT IT,
WHERE INMATES LAUGH ABOUT
OVERDOSING AND BRINGING BACK,
BEING BROUGHT BACK TO LIFE WITH
NARCAN. SO IT IS A REAL DEAL. DO
WE HAVE A PERCENTAGE OF, YOU
KNOW, FENTANYL USERS OR DRUG
USERS IN OUR CURRENT PRISON
SYSTEM? I DON'T HAVE ANY
NUMBERS, BUT I KNOW IT'S A
PROBLEM HERE. IT'S A PROBLEM IN
A LOT OF COUNTY JAILS. DO WE
HAVE IT IN OUR JAILS? DO YOU
HAVE A NUMBER FOR EVEN THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY JAILS? NO, BUT
IT HAPPENS. WE'VE HAD MULTIPLE
OVERDOSES BEHIND IT. WE'VE SAVED
A LOT OF FOLKS, BUT IT HAPPENS.
AND THEN AS FAR AS, YOU KNOW,
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT I HAVE
IN EVEN THE PREVIOUS
CONVERSATION, WHAT IS THE SINCE
YOU ARE A COUNTY SHERIFF, WHAT
IS THE TYPE OF TREATMENT THAT
WILL BE OFFERED TO THESE
INDIVIDUALS IF PROP 36 PASSES? I
THINK COURT MANDATED TREATMENT,
WHICH HAS PROVEN AND DRUG COURT
GOES WAY BACK, A LONG WAYS BACK,
AND THEY HAVE THE INFORMATION
AND THE INFORMATION THAT TALKS
ABOUT THE SUCCESS STORIES. AND
IT WORKS. IT'S PROVEN. WHAT DOES
THAT TREATMENT LOOK LIKE? THE
COURT MANDATES IT AND THROUGH
CBOS AND IT'S DONE OUT THERE. SO
I DON'T I'VE NEVER BEEN I'M NOT
A JUDGE. I'VE NEVER MET SOMEONE.
BUT I'VE SEEN THE RESULTS OF IT.
OKAY. DO WE KNOW HOW LONG THIS
TREATMENT LASTS? NO I DON'T I
DON'T HAVE THAT DETAILS. OKAY.
DO WE KNOW HOW MUCH IT WOULD
POTENTIALLY COST THE COUNTIES WE
PAID FOR IT BEFORE? IT'S STILL
THERE RIGHT NOW. IT'S JUST NOT
BEING USED. SO THE FOLKS THAT GO
RIGHT NOW TO DRUG, DRUG COURT
AND DRUG TREATMENT, THEY WANT TO
GET THEIR RECORDS EXPUNGED FOR A
JOB IS WHAT IT IS BASICALLY.
OKAY. AND WHY ISN'T IT BEING
USED RIGHT NOW? BECAUSE THE
COURT CAN'T FORCE THEM TO USE
IT. WHY NOT? UNDER PROP 47?
OKAY, SO IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY,
WE HAVE DRUG COURTS AND WE HAVE
ONE OF THE BIGGEST JUDGES.
THAT'S A LEADER EVEN IN THE
NATION, JUDGE MANLEY, THAT IS A
BIG PROPONENT OF THIS RIGHT
TREATMENT. SO I JUST WANT TO
UNDERSTAND WHY, YOU KNOW, IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY, WE CAN KIND
OF PUSH THIS. AND YET IN OTHER
COUNTIES, WE CANNOT THEY CAN
PUSH IT, BUT YOU CAN'T MANDATE
IT. AND THAT'S THE BIG ISSUE. SO
IF YOU LOOK AROUND AND TALKING
TO MY FELLOW SHERIFFS AND DA'S
THAT I KNOW FOR THE MAJORITY OF
THEM, BECAUSE THE COURTS CANNOT
MANDATE IT, THAT'S BEEN THE BIG
ISSUE. YOU MAY HAVE A JUDGE
WHO'S GOOD AND GREGARIOUS AND,
YOU KNOW, TALKS TO PEOPLE, BUT
THE AVERAGE JUDGE IS NOT GOING
TO FORCE SOMEONE INTO TREATMENT.
OKAY. BUT WE DO HAVE JUDGES
DISCRETION THAT WAS MENTIONED AS
WELL AS PROSECUTORIAL
DISCRETION. CORRECT. IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING IT'S NOT WHAT IT
WAS PRIOR TO PROP 47. OKAY. AND
THEN IN REGARDS TO THE RETAIL
THEFTS, YOU KNOW, YOU MENTIONED
THAT AND YOU KNOW, THE BILL
PACKAGE THAT WAS PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE THIS PAST YEAR AND
SIGNED INTO LAW, DO WE HAVE,
DATA AGAIN? I WANT TO BE VERY
SPECIFIC ON THE DATA IN REGARDS
TO THE CLOSURE RATES OF
SUCCESSFUL CASES THAT HAVE BEEN
COMPLETELY CLOSED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN REGARDS TO RETAIL
THEFT. WELL, THE GRANT JUST CAME
OUT, SO THE INFORMATION IS STILL
NEW. OKAY. BUT IN THE LAST
COURSE OF SEVERAL YEARS, DO WE
HAVE ANY DATA THAT SHOWS THE
SUCCESS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
CLOSING CASES THAT HAVE BEEN
OPENED BY THE PUBLIC THAT SAYS,
HEY, THIS ROBBERY TOOK PLACE OR
HEY, THINGS LIKE THAT, WHAT IS
THE CLOSURE RATE OR PERCENTAGE?
SO, SO ROBBERY IS DIFFERENT FROM
RETAIL THEFT OKAY. SO OBVIOUSLY
ROBBERY CASES. YES. BUT FOR
SIMPLE RETAIL THEFT ON THAT. AND
I KEEP GOING BACK SENATOR. IS
THAT FOR A LOT OF RETAIL THEFT.
IT IS A MISDEMEANOR. IT IS THE
SAME AS GRAFFITI OR BREAKING A
WINDOW. AND THAT'S BEEN THE BIG
ISSUE WITH IT. ARE THEY BEING
TRACKED IS NOT BEING TRACKED,
THIS TYPE OF MISDEMEANOR THAT
YOU WHEN IT'S REPORTED BUT IT'S
VASTLY UNDERREPORTED HERE IN THE
CITY OF SACRAMENTO, THE TARGET
ON BROADWAY, THE CITY GOT MAD AT
THEM FOR REPORTING IT SO MUCH
AND THREATENED TO FIND THEM. SO
HERE YOU HAVE THEY'RE HAVING A
PROBLEM. THEY'RE TRYING TO
REPORT IT, BUT YET THEY'RE BEING
FINED SO IT DOESN'T WORK. BOTH
WAYS OKAY. AND THEN SO THERE'S
NO CLEAR DATA ON EXACTLY. YOU
KNOW, SOME OF THE CLOSURES OF
YOU KNOW, SO IF AN AVERAGE
RESIDENT, YOU KNOW, FILLS OUT
THE PAPERWORK TO REPORT A CRIME
LIKE RETAIL THEFT OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT, EVEN A BUSINESS,
THERE'S NO CLEAR DATA ON THE
CLOSURE RATES IS WHAT I'M
UNDERSTANDING. WE DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES FOR THE MISDEMEANOR
STUFF THE DAY IN AND DAY OUT
STUFF BECAUSE OF PROP 47, THE
RESOURCES TO INVESTIGATE THOSE.
AND YOU BELIEVE WITH PROP 36,
YOU WILL HAVE THE RESOURCES.
YEAH. IT GIVES IT GIVES YOU A
HAMMER ON THAT TO DEAL WITH
THOSE INDIVIDUALS. AND HOW HOW
DO YOU GET RESOURCES THROUGH
THIS PROP 36? WELL, NUMBER ONE,
THE LEGISLATURE, YOU GUYS HELPED
US WITH THAT THROUGH THE FUNDING
ON THE ORC GRANT. THAT'S BEEN
VERY HELPFUL. AND I'LL TELL YOU,
THE BIG STORES CAN AFFORD THE
LOSSES. BUT REALLY, THE BACKBONE
OF SMALL BUSINESS IS SMALL AND
MOM AND POP STORES. THEY DON'T
HAVE A BOARD OF DIRECTORS OR
CORPORATE BOARD. THEY'RE TAKING
IT IN THEIR SHORTS AND THEY'RE
CLOSING. SO REALLY, YOU KNOW,
THAT'S MY EMPHASIS ON THE SMALL,
SMALL MOM AND POP THAT CAN'T
AFFORD TO SUSTAIN THE LOSSES.
AND THAT'S REALLY THE BIG ISSUE
WITH THAT. A LOT OF THEM DON'T
CALL IN. THEY DON'T REPORT IT TO
INSURANCE. THEY JUST TAKE IT IN
THE SHORTS. AND THAT'S THE BIG
ISSUE, HOW WE HELP THOSE SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE CLOSING
EVERY DAY 100%. AND DO WE TRULY
UNDERSTAND THE ROOT CAUSE OF
RETAIL THEFT AND DRUG ADDICTION?
I THINK WE DO A LOT, BUT I THINK
WITH THE ADVENT OF 47, WITH A
LOT OF THESE FOLKS WE'RE SEEING
RIGHT NOW, THEY'RE STILL GOING
TO BE STEALING BECAUSE THERE'S
NO ACCOUNTABILITY. THEY WILL NOT
GET IN TROUBLE. LIKE I SAID, WE
GO BACK TO THE FOLKS THAT STOLE
FOOD, 10%, FOLKS THAT WERE
HOMELESS, 15%. I'VE BEEN ON THE
OPERATIONS. THEY'RE HOUSED.
THEY'RE STEALING BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THEY CAN'T GET IN TROUBLE.
AND THAT'S THAT'S THE ISSUE.
IT'S HARD TO FATHOM THAT, BUT
THAT IS WHAT'S GOING ON OUT
THERE WITH BOOTS ON THE GROUND.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THE HOUSING
CRISIS HAS ANYTHING TO DO WITH
THE EXASPERATION OF, RETAIL
THEFT AND MUCH MORE? I DON'T
THINK IT PLAYS A BIG PART IN IT.
AND THAT GOES BACK TO FOLKS THAT
OFFERING HOUSING FOR THE
HOMELESS, A LOT OF THEM HAVE
TURNED IT DOWN BECAUSE OF MENTAL
ISSUES AND BECAUSE OF DRUG
ADDICTION ISSUES. BUT YET WE
DON'T WANT TO FORCE TREATMENT
FOR MENTAL ADDICTION OR
CONSERVANCY FOR SOME FOLKS. AND
WE DON'T WANT TO FORCE DRUG
TREATMENT. BUT HERE WE'RE HAVING
THE CONVERSATION BECAUSE OF PROP
47. ALL RIGHT. I APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU. DOES ANYBODY ELSE,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NGUYEN YEAH.
THANK YOU, CHAIR. AND THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE, YOU TALKED ABOUT
THE BILL PACKAGE THAT HAS BEEN
PASSED THROUGH HERE AND THERE
HAS BEEN SEVERAL BILLS THAT WE
PASSED HERE AS A LEGISLATOR
THROUGH JUST RETAIL THEFT AND
THE FENTANYL ISSUE, SOME MAY
ARGUE THAT THIS IS ENOUGH. THE
PACKAGE IS ENOUGH. IT MIGHT BE
EVEN STRETCHING IT. AND YET
WE'RE HERE. WE'RE HERE TALKING
ABOUT PROP 36. CAN YOU TALK
ABOUT THE DEFICIENCIES IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE AND HOW PROP
36 WOULD ADDRESS THIS, BUT ALSO
WHY IT'S NEEDED? SURE. SO TO FIX
THIS, JUST BE HONEST. IT DIDN'T
NEED 13 BILLS TO FIX PROP 47.
THAT'S JUST WHAT IT IS. IT COULD
HAVE BEEN ONE BILL THAT REALLY
DEALT WITH THE ISSUES ON IT. BUT
WE GOT 13 BILLS. AND FOR
INSTANCE, AGGREGATION. SO THE
STATE APPELLATE COURT SAID YOU
CANNOT AGGREGATE THEFT. WE
TALKED TO SOME OF THE FOLKS
BEHIND THIS BEHIND THE BILLS,
AND THEY'RE SAYING THEY THINK
THEY CAN. WELL, YOU HAVE A COURT
RULING THAT SAYS YOU CAN'T. YOU
HAVE A STATE SUPREME COURT
RULING THAT THE 950 LIMIT THAT
APPLIES TO CARS. WHO'S DRIVING A
CAR THAT COSTS LESS THAN $950,
AN IMMIGRANT, SOMEBODY BLACK OR
BROWN? NO ONE TALKS ABOUT THAT.
AND THAT'S THE BIG ISSUE WITH
THAT. SO WE'VE SEEN THAT. AND I
THINK 36 THE BIGGEST THING I
LIKE WHAT I LOVE IS DRUG
DIVERSION, DRUG DIVERSION, COURT
AND IT SAYS IN THERE IN BLACK
AND WHITE, IF YOU COMPLETE IT,
YOUR RECORDS EXPUNGED THAT THAT
IS HELPFUL. THAT'S TREMENDOUS
FOR THE CEREAL PEOPLE THAT ARE
COMING BACK AND BACK AND BACK
AGAIN. WE HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE
TO OUR SMALL BUSINESSES AND OUR
FOLKS, AND WE'RE ALL SUFFERING
RIGHT NOW. AND I THINK THAT'S
WHY THE PUBLIC BACKLASH IS
THERE. SO I THINK 36 IS A LOT
LIKE I SAID, WE GOT HERE BECAUSE
IT'S GOTTEN SO BAD. THAT'S THE
ONLY REASON WE'RE HERE. WE'RE
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION. THIS
COMMITTEE IS HERE BECAUSE OF
THAT. OTHERWISE THIS COMMITTEE
WASN'T HERE BETWEEN 2015 AND
LAST YEAR. THANK YOU, SENATOR
BRADFORD, THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SHERIFF, YOU MENTIONED THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF YOUR ORK
OPERATIONS. DOESN'T THAT PROVE
THAT THE CURRENT LAWS ARE
WORKING? IT HELPS OUT. BUT WHAT
IT IS THE OVERTIME, BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE TAKING FOLKS
FROM OTHER JOBS AND MAKING THEM
WORK. THE OVERTIME ON THIS
BECAUSE WE STILL HAVE PRIORITY
CALLS FOR SERVICES, FELONIES,
LIFE, HEALTH AND SAFETY. WE DEAL
WITH. AND THIS IS, LIKE I SAID,
THE WAY THE LAW IS, IT'S A
MISDEMEANOR. SO IF YOU CALL IN
BECAUSE SOMEONE DID A LAWN JOB
OR SLASHED YOUR TIRE, WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A REPORT OVER THE
PHONE. YOU'RE GOING TO GO ONLINE
AND DO THAT REPORT. SO THIS
GIVES US THE TOOLS AND RESOURCES
TO COMBAT IT. AND IT REALLY HAS
SLOWED IT DOWN SOME. IT HAS BEEN
EFFECTIVE. BUT THAT INFUSION OF
CASH IS THAT SUSTAINABLE? I
DON'T THINK SO. IT CAN'T GO ON
FOREVER. SO SOMETHING HAS TO
GIVE SOME WAY. AND WE'RE ALSO
HEARING REPORTS THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT I THINK YOU JUST
GAVE AN EXAMPLE, ARE NOT
RESPONDING TO MISDEMEANORS. IS
THAT NOT TRUE. WELL IT'S CALLS
FOR SERVICE. SO DEPENDING ON
WHAT IT IS, DOMESTIC VIOLENCE,
OTHER THINGS. DRUNK DRIVING.
YES. BUT IF SOMEONE COMES TO
YOUR HOUSE AND BREAKS YOUR FRONT
WINDOW, MOST AGENCIES WILL SAY,
HEY, FILE A REPORT ONLINE. WE'LL
TAKE THE REPORT OR SOMEONE WILL
TAKE IT. BUT AS FAR AS HAVING AN
OFFICER RESPOND BECAUSE WE'RE SO
OVERWHELMED WITH OTHER PRIORITY
CALLS, THAT'S BEEN THE BIG ISSUE.
AND AM I GOING TO HAVE SOMEONE
INVESTIGATE SOMEONE THAT BREAKS
YOUR WINDOW OUT? THAT'S NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN. I'M I'M NOT
GOING TO LIE TO YOU ABOUT THAT.
I DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES. I
WISH I DID, BUT DOESN'T THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO THE REPEAT
OFFENDERS OR OFFENSES? I SHOULD
SAY I THINK THESE REPEAT
OFFENDERS ARE DOING AS FAR AS
THE THEFT PIECE. THAT'S
DIFFERENT. I CONSIDER IT. BUT
WHEN THEY'RE COMING IN AND
STEALING, THEY KNOW HOW THE LAW
IS. THEY KNOW WHAT THEY CAN AND
CANNOT DO. WHEN SOMEONE BRINGS A
CALCULATOR IN, WHEN SOMEONE
SAYS, HEY, IT'S LESS THAN 950,
YOU CAN'T ARREST ME. SO IT'S
JUST THE BRAZENNESS AND IT TOOK
US A LONG WAY TO GET HERE. AND
THAT'S BEEN THE BIG ISSUE. SO
THAT'S THE THING IT'S BEEN GOING
ON FOR. SO LONG, YOU KNOW. SO
HOW DO YOU CHANGE THAT THAT
LEARNED BEHAVIOR. AND IF THIS
WERE THE PAST HOW WOULD WE
COMPARE TO OTHER STATES. SAY
TEXAS BECAUSE THEIR CURRENT
LEVEL IS $2000 OR $2500? I GUESS
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION, SENATOR.
BUT WHEN YOU ASK THE BUSINESS
OWNER THAT HAS THAT SMALL STORE,
THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY TO THEM,
TO MOST FOLKS. AND YOU THINK
ABOUT 950, THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY
TO GOING IN. AND THESE FOLKS ARE
BEING ROBBED BLIND, AND PEOPLE
JUST WALKING OUT WITH HANDFULS
OF STUFF. THE BIG STORES, THEY
WRITE IT OFF, THEY CHARGE US
HIGHER PRICES AS CONSUMER. BUT
FOR THOSE MOM AND SMALL POPS,
WHICH THE MAJORITY OF BUSINESSES
IN OUR STATE, IT'S
UNSUSTAINABLE. AND A LOT OF THEM
HAVE GONE OUT OF BUSINESS, I GET
THAT. SO I'M JUST CURIOUS WHY
DON'T YOU SEE THE SAME PATTERN?
YOU CAN'T ANSWER THIS. BUT IN
TEXAS, I MEAN, AGAIN, IF MY
THEFT LEVEL, MISDEMEANOR LEVEL
IS, IS NOT A FELONY UNTIL IT
GETS $2,500, WHY AREN'T THEY
RUNNING THOSE STORES, TOO? I
DON'T WANT TO BE COMPARED TO
ANYTHING IN TEXAS THEY GOT, BUT
THEY GOT A BUNCH OF BAD LAWS
OVER THERE AND OTHER THINGS. I
MEAN, I CAN'T WELL, TEXAS IS
MUCH MORE STRINGENT ON A LOT OF
OTHER THINGS, A LOT OF OTHER
LAWS THAN WE ARE. AND I THINK
THIS IS THIS, THIS IS A GOOD
APPROACH, AND I WISH IT WOULD
HAVE WENT THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE AND NOT HAD IT GONE
TO A BALLOT MEASURE. THERE WAS A
BALLOT MEASURE IN 2020, PROP 20,
FOR THE SAME THING. WE SHOULD
HAVE DONE THE BILL WHILE YOU
WERE HERE. I DID THAT IN THE
PROPOSITION. YES. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA. SORRY.
MELANIE'S SO SORRY, SHERIFF.
THANK YOU FOR COMING IN. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE. I THINK
JUST TO HELP OUT ALSO WITH THE
TEXAS QUESTION THAT HAD CAME UP,
I WAS ON THE SELECT COMMITTEE
FOR RETAIL THEFT THAT CAME UP
ALSO. I THINK THE BIGGEST PART
THAT CAME UP FOR TEXAS WAS,
DETERRENT. WHAT WAS WHAT WAS THE
WHAT WAS THE WHAT WAS THE
PUNISHMENT FOR THE CRIME? WELL,
IT WAS MUCH MORE HARSH THAN IT
IS HERE IN CALIFORNIA, WHICH, AS
YOU KNOW, WILL DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT SOMEBODY WILL COMMIT A
CRIME OR NOT. BUT I WAS HOPING
MAYBE YOU CAN ALSO EXPLAIN TO US
AND THOSE LISTENING, DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN A MISDEMEANOR AND A
FELONY, BECAUSE I FOUND WHEN I
CAME HERE TO THE LEGISLATION AS
A PRIOR LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER,
WE TALK ABOUT MISDEMEANORS. WE
TALK ABOUT FELONIES. AND I
ALWAYS WONDER, LIKE, WELL, WHY
AREN'T YOU DOING ANYTHING WITH
THE MISDEMEANOR? IF WE CAN MAYBE
TALK ABOUT ARRESTING WHILE IN
PRESENCE AND STUFF LIKE THAT, IF
YOU CAN JUST DEFINE THAT A
LITTLE BIT. SO A MISDEMEANOR IS
PUNISHABLE BY COUNTY JAIL TIME
AND A MISDEMEANOR IS NOT GOING
TO DO TIME IN THE JAIL BECAUSE
JAILS ARE RESERVED FOR FELONS.
WE FOR OUR MOST SERIOUS
OFFENDERS AND THAT'S BEEN THE
BIG ISSUE. AND WITH PROP I'M
SORRY AB109 YOU HAVE INMATES
THAT ARE GETTING SENTENCES 5 OR
7 YEARS THAT ARE SERVING THEIR
TIME IN THE COUNTY JAIL. AND
THAT'S THE BIG ISSUE WITH THAT.
SO BEFORE OBVIOUSLY A YEAR
LONGER, YOU WENT TO STATE PRISON
A YEAR OR LESS. YOU WERE IN
COUNTY JAIL. SO MISDEMEANORS AND
MISDEMEANORS FOR THE MOST PART
DON'T COME. THE ONLY TIME
SOMEONE'S IN JAIL FOR
MISDEMEANOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OR
A DUI AND COURT ORDER,
TYPICALLY. OTHERWISE, I'LL BE
HONEST, WE DON'T HAVE
MISDEMEANORS IN JAIL. AND
SHERIFF, IF, LET'S SAY I WAS TO
COMMIT A MISDEMEANOR, YOU DID
NOT SEE IT. DID YOU NOT SEE IT?
SOME WILL COME IN AND BOOK THEM.
SOMETIMES WE'LL SIGN THEM OUT
RIGHT AWAY. JUST BECAUSE OF
JAIL, OVERCROWDING AND CONSENT
DECREE. IT IS. IF YOU'RE IN
JAIL, IT'S BECAUSE YOU GOT SOME
SERIOUS CHARGES, NOT ON A
MISDEMEANOR. WITH THE TWO
EXCEPTIONS I MENTIONED EARLIER.
GOTCHA. YES. AND SO? SO IF IT'S
TRUE OR NOT, IF YOU CAN ANSWER
THIS, ARE A LOT OF THE ARRESTS
DOWN BECAUSE THESE MISDEMEANORS
ARE NOT TAKEN IN THE PLACE OF A
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER.
CORRECT. AND I'LL POINT TO THE
DRUG ISSUES A LOT OF FOLKS DON'T
ARREST ON DRUGS THESE DAYS.
WE'RE NOT WE SAW THE ARREST DROP
ON THAT. THE PROBLEM IS STILL
THERE. ADDICTION IS STILL THERE.
YOU'RE JUST NOT SEEING FOLKS
ARRESTED BECAUSE IT'S A
MISDEMEANOR. SO THEN BACK TO THE
FURTHER QUESTION THAT THE
SENATOR WAS ASKING YOU ABOUT
CLOSING OUT CALLS. I THINK THIS
KIND OF GOES TO THE MISDEMEANOR
PART. IS IT HARDER TO PROVE THE
MISDEMEANOR AS OPPOSED TO THE
FELONY, OR IS IT EASIER FOR ME
TO MAKE AN ARREST ON A FELONY
THAT WASN'T COMMITTED IN MY
PRESENCE, AS OPPOSED TO A
MISDEMEANOR THAT WASN'T
COMMITTED IN MY PRESENCE, THAT I
DON'T HAVE ANYBODY SIGNING A
CITIZEN'S ARREST FORM OR
SOMEBODY WHO'S COMING FORWARD TO
SAY, I WANT SOMEBODY ARRESTED.
IT'S EASIER ON A FELONY, MUCH
EASIER. THANK YOU, AND I WANT TO
BE VERY CLEAR IN REGARDS TO THE
$950, IT'S CONSIDERED A WOBBLER,
CORRECT? CORRECT. OKAY. AND A
WOBBLER CAN BE CHARGED AS A
FELONY OR A MISDEMEANOR.
CORRECT? CORRECT. AND IT COULD
BE PUNISHABLE WITH JAIL TIME.
CORRECT? CORRECT OKAY. SO WE DO
HAVE THOSE ON THE BOOKS RIGHT
NOW BASED ON PROP 47. YEAH. BUT
THE DRUG THING IS I'LL BE HONEST
WITH YOU SEEING HOW IT'S APPLIED,
IT'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE ON A
MISDEMEANOR AND A LOT OF
WOBBLERS, TO BE HONEST. BUT IS
THAT PROSECUTORIAL DISCRETION OR
JUDGE'S DISCRETION? I WOULD SAY
BOTH. WHETHER IT'S CHARGED OR
SENTENCED. OKAY. BUT OVERALL,
YOU KNOW, THIS TYPE OF THEFT,
THE $950 THAT WE HEAR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS COMPLAIN ABOUT DAILY ARE
NOT REALLY BEING EVEN PURSUED.
THEY ARE BEING PURSUED OVER 950
OVER AND BUT ANYTHING UNDER 950
IS NOT BEING PURSUED. CORRECT.
IT'S A MISDEMEANOR. AND RIGHT
NOW SACRAMENTO COUNTY, I HAVE
30,000 OUTSTANDING MISDEMEANOR
WARRANTS BECAUSE PEOPLE JUST
DON'T SHOW UP FOR COURT. THE
FTAS ARE A BIG ISSUE AND WE'VE
GOT A WHOLE BUNCH OF FELONY
WARRANTS ALSO. BUT WAY MORE
MISDEMEANOR WARRANTS. THEY JUST
DON'T SHOW UP AND NO ONE HAS.
AND THE GOAL OF PROP 36 IS
BECAUSE PROSECUTING A FELONY IS
EASIER, AS YOU STATED. CORRECT.
AND THOSE ARE PROLIFIC CRIMINALS
ON THAT ON THE THEFT PIECE AND
THE FENTANYL PIECE HAS A
SEPARATE TRACK. AND YOU STATED
JAIL IS NOT WHERE IT IS WHERE
PEOPLE. I'M SO SORRY YOU STATED
SOMETHING LIKE, AND YOU COULD
CORRECT ME IF I MISHEARD,
FELONIES. PEOPLE WHO COMMIT
FELONIES ARE AWAITING TRIAL OR,
MISDEMEANORS ARE NOT HELD OR
SOMETHING TO THAT EFFECT.
CORRECT ONLY MISDEMEANORS THAT
ARE HELD ARE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
OR DUI OR A COURT ORDERED THING.
AND THOSE ARE A SMALL
PERCENTAGE. OKAY, I APPRECIATE
IT. I APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION AND ANSWERING ALL
THE QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SENATOR. ONE CLARIFICATION
YES, I THINK WHAT NEEDS TO
REALLY BE CLEARLY UNDERSTOOD,
IT'S NOT ONLY EASIER FOR AN
OFFICER TO MAKE A FELONY ARREST,
BUT UNLESS THE CRIME IS
COMMITTED IN THE PRESENCE OF AN
OFFICER AND A MISDEMEANOR, YOU
HAVE NO AUTHORITY TO PLACE
SOMEONE UNDER ARREST UNLESS YOU
HAVE SOMEBODY WHO WITNESSED THE
CRIME MAKE A CITIZEN'S ARREST.
SO I THINK THAT THAT'S NOT
UNDERSTOOD BY MOST PEOPLE. SO IF
YOU HAVE AN OFFENSE THAT'S A
MISDEMEANOR, A PEACE OFFICER
CANNOT PLACE SOMEBODY UNDER
ARREST UNLESS THEY HAVE SOMEBODY
WHO WITNESSED THE CRIME. BE
WILLING TO PLACE THAT PERSON
UNDER CITIZEN'S ARREST. AND I
DON'T THINK THAT'S UNDERSTOOD BY
MOST PEOPLE. THANK YOU. AND I
WOULD LOVE TO HEAR THE SHERIFF
MAKE ANY COMMENTS ABOUT THAT,
INCLUDING THE FACT THAT MANY
RESIDENTS, YOU KNOW, HAVE VIDEO
CAM FOOTAGE THAT IS CLEAR
EVIDENCE IN 4K AND 8-K THAT
CLEARLY SHOWS AN INDIVIDUAL'S
FACE COMMITTING POTENTIALLY A
CRIME. ALL THE BIG BOX RETAILERS
THAT HAVE SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
CAMERAS AND SECURITY AND
SURVEILLANCE, INCLUDING SECURITY
GUARDS THAT, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE
COMMIT A CRIME AND WALK OUT OF
THE STORE. AND YET NOTHING IS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW. COULD YOU
BE ABLE TO EXPLAIN THAT? I THINK
YOU TALK ABOUT CAPACITY. YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT RESPONDING TO
CALLS FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE, FOR
ROBBERIES, FOR BURGLARIES,
VEHICLE BURGLARIES, BUSINESS
BURGLARIES. SO A LOT OF THINGS
WE ONLY HAVE SO MUCH CAPACITY. I
DON'T HAVE A MILLION OFFICERS.
IF I HAD A MILLION OFFICERS, I
WOULD RESPOND TO EVERY CRIME.
AND THAT'S EVERY AGENCY AROUND.
SO DO YOU BELIEVE WITH PROP 36,
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE FULL
CAPACITY TO PROSECUTE THESE
CRIMES? IT WILL HELP WITH THE
FREQUENT FLIERS, SO TO SPEAK.
OUR MOST PROLIFIC PEOPLE THAT DO
THAT, IT WILL IT WILL GIVE US A
TOOL TO REALLY DEAL WITH THEM.
AND FOR THE MOST PART, A LOT OF
HOMEOWNERS, WHEN THEY HAVE
THINGS HAPPEN, THEY DON'T REPORT
IT. THAT'S JUST A FACT OF
NATURE. MOST DON'T REPORT IT
BECAUSE POTENTIALLY IT'S NOT
PURSUED RIGHT? BECAUSE OF THE
LACK OF ABILITY, RESOURCES.
THAT'S PART OF IT, DEPENDING ON
WHAT THE CRIME IS. ALL RIGHT.
SOME WE DO THOUGH, AND WE DO
BELIEVE THAT AND FACTUALLY AND
AGAIN BASED ON DATA, WE DO HAVE
A HUGE, LET'S SAY OUR POLICE
RANKS ARE NOT COMPLETELY FILLED
IN EVERY CITY AND EVERY COUNTY.
CORRECT WE HAVE VACANCIES.
CORRECT. AT ROUGHLY ABOUT WHAT
PERCENTAGE ACROSS THE BOARD CHP
IS DOWN 1000 OFFICERS. I'M DOWN
100. SO EVERYBODY'S DOWN AND
THEY'RE DOING SIGNING BONUSES UP
TO $100,000. NO ONE WANTS TO BE
A COP. THE LEGISLATURE MADE IT
HARDER. NOW YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
DEGREE IN TWO YEARS. SO IT IS
TOUGH TO HIRE IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT. NO ONE'S CALLING
YOU BECAUSE YOU HAD A GOOD DAY,
SENATOR. THEY'RE CALLING YOU
BECAUSE CRAP IS HAPPENING, OKAY?
AND YOU DISAGREE WITH THE
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS. NUMBER
ONE, WHEN I CAME IN, I ONLY HAD
I'D BEEN IN COLLEGE FOR A YEAR
OR TWO. MOST FOLKS DON'T HAVE
IT, COMMON SENSE IS WHAT PLAYS
OUT TO THAT. JUST BECAUSE YOU
HAVE A DEGREE DOESN'T MAKE YOU
HAVE GOOD COMMON SENSE. AND
THAT'S WHAT IT COMES DOWN TO.
AND SCREENING AND BACKGROUNDS.
OTHERWISE I WOULDN'T BE HERE
RIGHT NOW. AND A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE BLACK AND BROWN THAT
DON'T HAVE A FOUR YEAR DEGREE,
THEY DON'T HAVE MOM AND DAD
PAYING FOR IT, OR THEY CAN STAY
AT HOME AND DO THAT. THEY DON'T
HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY.
UNDERSTOOD. AND THEN AS FAR AS
MENTAL HEALTH CALLS AND HOMELESS
CALLS, DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
SHOULD BE, YOU KNOW, PART OF THE
SCOPE OF WORK OF POLICE
OFFICERS? I BELIEVE SOMEONE ELSE
SHOULD RESPOND TO THOSE CALLS
DEPENDING ON WHAT IT IS. OKAY.
AND THAT WOULD HELP WITH
CAPACITY. CORRECT. AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT WANTS THAT. BUT
QUITE OFTEN THESE THINGS INVOLVE
OTHER THINGS. AND NOT JUST THE
MENTALLY ILL. THERE INVOLVES A
WHOLE RANGE OF THINGS. ALL
RIGHT. I SUPPORT SOMETHING LIKE
THAT I APPRECIATE THAT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU SENATOR.
ALL RIGHT. OUR NEXT PRESENTER
WILL BE COUNCIL MEMBER MARK. AND
I APOLOGIZE IF I MISPRONOUNCED
YOUR LAST NAME. MANZANO. CITY OF
REDDING, LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA.
CITIES. YOU ACTUALLY GOT IT,
RIGHT? GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
MCCARTY AND CHAIR, MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. IT'S AN HONOR TO
BE HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY. MY
NAME IS MARK MANZANO. I'M A 29
YEAR VETERAN OF THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL. I'M CURRENTLY A
COUNCIL MEMBER FOR THE CITY OF
REDDING, AND I'M HERE TO TESTIFY
ON PROP 36 ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES, ONE
OF CAL CITIES PRIORITIES IN 2024
WAS TO ADDRESS RETAIL THEFT,
SHOPLIFTING AND CRIME WITHOUT
GOING BACK TO THE DAYS OF MASS
INCARCERATION. CAL CITIES WAS IN
SUPPORT OF THE MOST OF THE
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE ON RETAIL
THEFT, AND WE BELIEVE THE
PACKAGE CAN WORK IN CONCERT WITH
PROPOSITION 36. THE CAL CITIES
BOARD VOTED TO SUPPORT
PROPOSITION 36 ON JULY 11TH,
AFTER HEARING FROM BOTH
PROPONENTS AND OPPONENTS OF THE
MEASURE. UNFORTUNATELY, PROP 47
HAS LED TO UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OVER THE PAST
DECADE, CITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE ARE EXPERIENCING A SPIKE
IN REPEAT AND ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT, THE SHUTTERING OF LOCAL
BUSINESSES, AND AN INCREASE IN
FENTANYL RELATED OVERDOSES.
CITIES ALSO REPORT THAT IT IS
BECOMING INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT
AT THE STATE SINCE 2020 TO
CONVINCE PEOPLE TO SEEK DRUG AND
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT.
COMMERCIAL BURGLARY HAS
INCREASED ACROSS THE STATE SINCE
2020. THIS IS ESPECIALLY EVIDENT
IN THE LARGER COUNTIES, WITH AN
INCREASE OF 13% AMONG 14 OF THE
15 LARGEST COUNTIES.
CALIFORNIA'S OPIOID RELATED
DEATHS HAVE SKYROCKETED 121% IN
THE LAST THREE YEARS. OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE OVERWHELMED, AND
THE STATUS QUO IS NOT WORKING.
CITY OFFICIALS ARE HEARING FROM
THEIR RESIDENTS, LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS AND SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS THAT THESE ARE THERE ARE
GAPS IN OUR SYSTEM. WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THE PIECES OF PROP 47
THAT ARE MAKING IT HARDER FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICIALS TO KEEP
OUR COMMUNITIES SAFE. CAL CITIES
IS IN SUPPORT OF PROP 36 BECAUSE
IT ADDRESSES ONE OF THE KEY
ISSUES THAT THE LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE DOES NOT, AND THAT IS
AMENDING PROP 47 TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
ONE OF THE MAJOR ISSUES THAT CAL
CITIES HAS BEEN TRYING TO
ADDRESS IS REPEAT OFFENDERS, AND
WE DO NOT BELIEVE YOU CAN
ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
WITHOUT AMENDING PROP 47.
PROPOSITION 47 REPEALED THE
PENAL CODE FELONY THEFT WITH A
PRIOR, WHICH HAS UNFORTUNATELY
RESULTED IN THE INABILITY FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO IDENTIFY AND
POTENTIALLY DIVERT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS TO THE CORRECT
TREATMENT AND SERVICES.
CURRENTLY, MANY CITIES AND
BUSINESSES ARE EXPERIENCING
DAILY SHOPLIFTING WITHOUT A WAY
TO IDENTIFY THOSE INDIVIDUALS
AND TO TRY AND PREVENT
ADDITIONAL REPEAT SHOPLIFTING
FROM OCCURRING. PROPOSITION 36
IS A COMMON SENSE, BIPARTISAN
EFFORT THAT BRINGS BACK THE
TOOLS WE NEED TO MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFER AND CONNECT
OUR MOST VULNERABLE TO THE
SERVICES THEY DESERVE.
PROPOSITION 36 WILL HOLD, REPEAT
RETAIL THEFT OFFENDERS AND
SERIOUS DRUG TRAFFICKERS
ACCOUNTABLE, WHILE INCENTIVIZING
DRUG TREATMENT FOR THOSE WITH
SERIOUS ADDICTIONS. FOR EXAMPLE,
THE MEASURE ALLOWS JUDGES TO
SENTENCE CONVICTED DRUG DEALERS
WHO TRAFFIC IN LARGE QUANTITIES
OF HARD DRUGS, INCLUDING
FENTANYL, AND AUTHORIZED GREATER
CONSEQUENCES FOR THE HARD DRUG
DEALERS. PROP PROPOSITION 36 IS
NOT, AND I SAY NOT ABOUT
RETURNING TO THE ERA OF MASS
INCARCERATION. IT PROVIDES
SMART, TAILORED TOOLS THAT HELP
PROTECT OUR BUSINESSES AND
CREATE SAFER COMMUNITIES. CAL
CITIES HAS BEEN TRYING TO
EFFECTUATE CHANGE IN RETAIL
THEFT, SHOPLIFTING AND FENTANYL
ISSUES FOR SEVERAL YEARS WITHOUT
MUCH SUCCESS. WE APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE ADDRESSING SOME OF
THE ISSUES THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE, BUT OUR
MEMBERS STILL BELIEVE THAT THE
CHANGES IN PROP 36 WILL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TOOLS FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS TO ADDRESS THE SURGE
IN CRIME THAT HAS BEEN OCCURRING
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. IN
CONCLUSION, I WANT TO THANK BOTH
THE LEGISLATURE AND BOTH PUBLIC
SAFETY POLICY COMMITTEES FOR
THEIR ATTENTION TO THESE
IMPORTANT CRIME ISSUES THAT HAVE
PLAGUED OUR COMMUNITIES SINCE
2014. CAL CITIES WANTS COMMON
SENSE SOLUTIONS THAT WILL KEEP
OUR CITIES SAFER, PROTECT OUR
RESIDENTS, AND ALLOW SMALL
BUSINESSES TO STAY IN BUSINESS.
THANK YOU. AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. SAYING WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
PANEL. OPPONENTS OF THE MEASURE.
OUR FIRST SPEAKER WILL BE
CHRISTIN SOTO DEBERRY, EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF PROSECUTORS,
ALLIANCE ACTION. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CHAIRS. MEMBERS OF
THE SELECT COMMITTEE HAPPY TO BE
HERE WITH ALL OF YOU TODAY.
CHRISTIN SOTO, I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF PROSECUTORS ALLIANCE
ACTION. WE WORK WITH LINE
PROSECUTORS, VICTIM ADVOCATES
AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS ACROSS THE
STATE. OVER 4000 MEMBERS IN MOST
COUNTIES IN THE STATE. I'VE
SPENT MOST OF MY CAREER IN
GOVERNMENT AS A PUBLIC DEFENDER
IN SAN FRANCISCO, LOCAL
GOVERNMENT, OVERSEEING POLICE
DEPARTMENTS AND THEN TEN YEARS
RUNNING, ONE OF THE LARGEST
PROSECUTORS OFFICES IN THE
STATE. AND I HAVE SEEN THE CRIME
TRENDS THAT HAPPEN OVER TIME. MY
TIME IN THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE, WE HAD A PROBLEM WITH
SMARTPHONE THEFTS. WE HAD A
PROBLEM WITH RETAIL THEFT. WE
HAD A PROBLEM WITH CAR
BURGLARIES. AND WHEN THOSE
ISSUES CAME UP, WE FOUND
SOLUTIONS WITH THE EXISTING
TOOLS IN OUR TOOLBOX TO SOLVE
THEM. WHEN SMARTPHONE THEFTS WAS
A PROBLEM, WE LOOKED AT UPSTREAM
SOLUTIONS, MUCH LIKE THE ONE
THAT THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY JUST
PASSED AROUND RETAIL THEFT TO
FOCUS ON SHUTTING DOWN THE
MARKET FOR THOSE STOLEN GOODS.
WHEN WE HAD A PROBLEM AROUND
RETAIL THEFT, MUCH LIKE WE'VE
SEEN IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE, WE INVESTED IN LARGE
SCALE INVESTIGATIONS TO
UNDERSTAND WHO WERE THE REPEAT
ORGANIZED DRIVERS OF THAT
ACTIVITY, TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
COULD WORK WITH OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO
APPREHEND THOSE INDIVIDUALS,
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE IN COURT,
AND HAVE APPROPRIATE
CONSEQUENCES. THE GOOD NEWS IS,
ALL OF THOSE TOOLS EXIST TODAY.
FROM WHAT YOU'RE HEARING ABOUT
PROP 36, YOU WOULD THINK IT'S A
$200 BILLION FUNDING MEASURE
THAT'S GOING TO PUT MORE POLICE
OFFICERS IN COMMUNITIES, THAT'S
GOING TO FUND TREATMENT IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES. AND IT DOES NONE OF
THOSE THINGS. WHAT IT DOES IS
ADD MORE LOW LEVEL OFFENSES INTO
THE STATE PRISON ELIGIBLE
CATEGORY. AND SUGGEST TO US THAT
THAT IS GOING TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM. THE LIMITATION OF THAT
IS DATA AND DECADES OF
EXPERIENCE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
SHOW US THAT THAT IS NOT TRUE.
WHAT DETERS CRIME IS THE
LIKELIHOOD OF GETTING CAUGHT. WE
JUST HEARD FROM THE PREVIOUS
SHERIFF THAT MOST OF THESE CASES
ARE NOT EVEN RESPONDED TO
SENATOR WAHAB'S QUESTION ABOUT
THE SOLVE RATE IN CALIFORNIA,
THE SOLVE RATE FOR PROPERTY
THEFT IS 8%. PROP 36 WILL NOT
CHANGE THAT. THERE WILL NOT BE
MORE DEPUTIES IN THE SACRAMENTO
SHERIFF'S OFFICE TO RESPOND TO
TARGET, OR A MOM AND POP STORE,
WHETHER IT'S A MISDEMEANOR OR A
FELONY. WE ARE NOT GOING TO
CHANGE THIS PROBLEM THAT WAY.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT THAT'S
WHAT'S BEING TOLD TO VOTERS THAT
WE WANT TREATMENT, BUT WE'RE NOT
FUNDING TREATMENT. IN FACT,
WE'RE DOING THE EXACT OPPOSITE.
WITH THIS BALLOT MEASURE, WE
WILL LOSE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS THAT CURRENTLY GO TO
FUND THE KINDS OF TREATMENT THAT
THE PROPONENTS ARE SAYING THEY
WANT. WE ALL AGREE ON THAT. WE
ALL AGREE ON TREATMENT, BUT WHAT
IS NOT AGREED UPON IS THAT IT
NEEDS TO BE FUNDED, THAT IT
NEEDS TO BE A PRIORITY. SO IT IS
IT IS UNFORTUNATE TO SEE THAT
BEING PUSHED AS LIKE PROP 36
WILL BRING TREATMENT. THE
DIFFERENCE IS PROP 36 WILL HOLD
A FELONY OVER SOMEBODY'S HEAD
AND SAY, NOW YOU MUST DO
TREATMENT. BUT IF A COUNTY DOES
NOT HAVE THAT TREATMENT
AVAILABLE, IT WILL NOT BE GIVEN.
THERE IS NO MONEY IN THIS
PROPOSITION TO ENSURE THAT THAT
TREATMENT IS AVAILABLE. AND
TAKEN UP AND USED BY THE
INDIVIDUAL IN NEED OF IT. NONE.
IN FACT, WHAT WE WILL DO IS LOSE
THE VERY SMART WORK WE HAVE DONE
COLLECTIVELY OF SAYING WE WANT
TO TREAT PROBLEMS WITH THE RIGHT
SOLUTION. IF SOMEBODY IS
STRUGGLING WITH ADDICTION OR
MENTAL HEALTH, WE WANT TO TREAT
THAT. WE DON'T WANT TO PUT THEM
IN A JAIL OR A PRISON. THAT WILL
MAKE THAT SITUATION WORSE, WHERE
APPARENTLY THEY CAN STILL GET
DRUGS WE'RE HEARING. SO WE NEED
TO FOCUS ON THE SOLUTIONS THAT
WORK TO SOLVE THE PROBLEMS.
INCREASING PUNISHMENTS DOES NOT
DETER CRIME. YOU DON'T HAVE TO
BELIEVE ME. YOU CAN LOOK TO OUR
US DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF JUSTICE
HAS STUDIED THIS AND THEY TELL
US REPEATEDLY WHAT DETERS CRIME
IS THE LIKELIHOOD OF GETTING
CAUGHT. SO IF WE ARE WORRIED
ABOUT THE AMOUNT OF DRUGS BEING
CONSUMED IN OUR COMMUNITIES OR
THE KINDS OF THEFTS THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING, WE NEED TO START
THERE. WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
PREVENTION INSTEAD OF REACTION
AFTER THE FACT. IT'S ONE THING
TO SAY WE WANT TREATMENT. IT'S A
WHOLE NOTHER THING TO FUND IT.
AND I HOPE THAT THIS LEGISLATIVE
BODY AND THE VOTERS WILL PAY
ATTENTION TO WHAT'S ACTUALLY AT
STAKE. WE ARE GOING TO LOSE
DESPERATELY NEEDED FUNDING FOR
TREATMENT WITH THIS MEASURE.
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS? ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY.
YEAH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. THE
BALLOT REBUTTAL ARGUMENT. TO IN
FAVOR OF PROP 36, WHICH YOU
SIGNED, SAYS THE FOLLOWING. AND
I QUOTE THIS MEASURE IS SO IS
ALSO SO POORLY DRAFTED THAT IT
WILL SIMPLY CREATE CONFUSION IN
THE COURTS AND NOT LEAD TO
HIGHER PENALTIES. IN MANY RETAIL
THEFT CASES, END QUOTE. SO CAN
YOU CLARIFY WHAT PROVISIONS THE
COURT WILL BE UNABLE TO
UNDERSTAND? WHAT WHERE'S THE
AMBIGUITY THAT YOU REFER TO?
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION. I
THINK THE SITUATION WE WILL END
UP WITH IN COURTS IS WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE AS WE SEE NOW, IT
WILL VARY BY JURISDICTION. WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A WHOLE NEW SET OF
LAWS COME ON THE BOOKS, AND A
LACK OF CLARITY ABOUT WHAT IS
MISDEMEANOR CONDUCT, WHAT IS
FELONY CONDUCT. WE HEARD A LOT
IN THE EARLIER PRESENTATIONS
ABOUT PROSECUTORIAL DISCRETION,
AND I THINK THAT WILL COME INTO
PLAY. WE WILL SEE COUNTIES THAT
ENFORCE MUCH HARSHER CHARGING
AND PURSUE MUCH HARSHER
SENTENCING THAN OTHERS. I DON'T
THINK WE'LL SEE IN REDUCTIONS IN
CRIME AS A RESULT OF THAT. BUT I
DO BELIEVE THAT BY WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE COMPETING AGGREGATION, A
CONVERSATIONS THAT NEED TO BE
HAD. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
CONFUSION AROUND THE MURDER
ADVISORY. THERE'S GOING TO BE
MANY THINGS THAT ARE GOING TO
CREATE CONFUSION IN THE COURTS.
MY ONLY ANSWER WITH THAT TO THAT
WOULD BE THAT DISCRETION IS NOT
TO BE CONFUSED WITH AMBIGUITY,
IN MY OPINION, BUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, I DID WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF THINGS
THAT YOU MENTIONED, YOU KNOW,
I'M A BIG PROPONENT OF
TREATMENT. I TRULY BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS IMPORTANT FOR SOCIETY TO
HAVE TREATMENT OPTIONS
AVAILABLE, BOTH, YOU KNOW, IN
JUST REGULAR ADDICTION THAT
THERE IS NO CRIME COMMITTED
WHETHER THAT'S ALCOHOLISM,
WHETHER THAT'S, YOU KNOW, DRUG
ADDICTION AND SO FORTH. BUT ONE
OF THE MAIN PROBLEMS THAT I'VE
SEEN IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE
AND, YOU KNOW, TACKLING THIS
ISSUE OF TREATMENT, IS THAT
THERE IS TODAY NOT ENOUGH BEDS,
NOT ENOUGH SPACES, SOME COUNTIES
AND AGAIN, I REPRESENT TWO
DIFFERENT COUNTIES. AND WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE 58
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA, THEIR
FUNDING RESOURCES VARY GREATLY.
AND AS WAS PRESENTED IN THE
EARLIER, PRESENTATIONS THAT THIS
WOULD VARY BASED ON COUNTY AND
COUNTY WOULD BE THE ONES THAT
WOULD HAVE TO PAY INTO SOME TYPE
OF EFFORT, COULD YOU ELABORATE A
LITTLE BIT MORE ON WHETHER OR
NOT WE HAVE BEDS? AND LET'S SAY
THAT AN INDIVIDUAL DOES SELECT
TREATMENT AS THEIR OPTION, AND
THERE IS NO BEDS AVAILABLE FOR
THEM TO BE TREATED. WHAT HAPPENS
TO THEM? YEAH, THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION. SO, YOU KNOW, I SPENT
TEN YEARS IN A COUNTY THAT'S
RELATIVELY SERVICE RICH. SAN
FRANCISCO COUNTY DOES A VERY
GOOD JOB OF PRIORITIZING
TREATMENT AND SERVICES FOR
PEOPLE COMING THROUGH THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. WE DID
NOT HAVE ENOUGH TREATMENT
SPACES, EITHER INPATIENT OR
OUTPATIENT, EVER, AT ANY TIME IN
THE DECADE THAT I SERVED THERE.
DID WE HAVE ADEQUATE TREATMENT?
AND THAT WAS NOT FOR PEOPLE, NOT
CARING ABOUT THE ISSUE. ARE ALL
OF OUR MAYORS AND OUR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WERE REPEATEDLY
ALLOCATING PUBLIC HEALTH
RESOURCES TO TRY AND MEET THAT
NEED. WE SIMPLY WERE INCAPABLE
OF THAT. AND THAT IS IN A REALLY
UNFORTUNATE COUNTY. THERE ARE
MORE COUNTIES IN THIS STATE THAN
NOT THAT DON'T HAVE ANY
TREATMENT, PARTICULARLY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. IN THE MORE
RURAL COMMUNITIES, IT IS VERY
HARD TO FUND AND SUSTAIN THOSE
KINDS OF PROGRAMS. SO WHEN
SOMEONE COMES TO COURT AND SAYS,
YES, YOUR HONOR, I WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE TREATMENT, THE JUDGE WILL
SAY, GREAT PROBATION, PLEASE
FIND THEM. TREATMENT BED. AND
THEY DEPENDING ON THE CASE, THEY
WILL EITHER KEEP THEM IN CUSTODY
WHILE THEY LOOK FOR THAT BED OR
THEY WILL RELEASE THEM. EVEN THE
INDIVIDUALS IN CUSTODY AFTER A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME OF NOT
FINDING A TREATMENT BED, THEY
WILL COME BACK TO COURT AND ASK
TO BE RELEASED UNTIL THAT
TREATMENT IS AVAILABLE. OR THEY
WILL SAY, JUST GIVE ME THE JAIL
TIME AND I DON'T WANT TO DO THE
TREATMENT AND CURRENTLY THE
MEASURE SAYS STATE PRISON,
CORRECT? YES OKAY. AND SO EVEN
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE SEEKING
TREATMENT WITH THE GOAL AND
OBVIOUSLY THE STATEMENT FROM THE
PROPONENTS THAT EVEN IF A PERSON
WANTS TREATMENT, EVEN IF THE
JUDGE WANTS TO GIVE TREATMENT,
EVEN IF THE DA WANTS TO GIVE
TREATMENT, IT'S PRISON TIME,
CORRECT? YOU CAN WANT IT. BUT IF
IT DOESN'T EXIST, IT IS AN
IMPOSSIBLE THING FOR ANY OF US
TO DELIVER TO THE PERSON. AND
THERE IS NO UNIFORMITY IN THE
FUNDING MECHANISM FOR THE
DIFFERENT COUNTIES. SO A RURAL
COUNTY WITH FAR MORE NEED IN SO
MANY DIFFERENT WAYS WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE A LOT OF THE
RESOURCES FOR TREATMENT.
CORRECT. THERE'S $0 ATTACHED TO
THIS, AND IT WILL REDUCE THAT
EVEN FURTHER, TAKING AWAY THE
FEW DOLLARS THAT DO EXIST AND
REDIRECTING THEM TO JAILS AND
PRISONS. OKAY. AND IT WAS STATED
IN THE LAST PRESENTATION THAT
THE PRIORITY CALLS LIKE A DUI,
LIKE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE, LIKE,
YOU KNOW, GOD FORBID, RAPE AND
MURDER AND SO FORTH ARE PRIORITY
CALLS, WITH THIS BALLOT MEASURE,
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT EVEN IF THE
VOTERS VOTED FOR THIS, THAT
RETAIL THEFT AND, DRUG CRIMES
WOULD BE PRIORITIZED, NOT NO,
NOR SHOULD THEY, RIGHT? OVER A
CRIME OF VIOLENCE, AS YOU SAY
SOMETHING AS SERIES, AS A SEXUAL
ASSAULT OR A GUN. THOSE WILL
ALWAYS BE THE TOP PRIORITY OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT, AS WE WOULD
EXPECT. THEY WOULD BE THEFT,
WHETHER IT HAS A MISDEMEANOR
NEXT TO IT OR A FELONY NEXT TO
IT, IS GOING TO FALL BENEATH
THOSE AND WILL NOT BE RESPONDED
TO ANY DIFFERENTLY. OKAY. AND SO
WHY DO YOU BELIEVE THE
PROPONENTS BELIEVE THAT THIS
WILL MAKE A DENT IN THE CRIMES
THAT WE SEE? I WON'T SPECULATE
ON THAT, BUT I WOULD ENCOURAGE
US ALL TO THINK MORE ABOUT THE
KINDS OF INVESTIGATIVE TOOLS WE
HAVE THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
FUNDED UP AND DOWN THE STATE AS
A MUCH MORE EFFECTIVE WAY TO
APPREHEND AND REDUCE THIS KIND
OF THEFT THAN INCREASING
PUNISHMENTS ON THE BACK END.
OKAY. AND THEN THE FACT THAT
SOME HAVE STATED THAT ON A
WOBBLER, THE $950 THAT'S OFTEN
DEBATED IN THE PUBLIC, CAN THAT
BE PURSUED TODAY UNDER CURRENT
LAW? VIA PROP 47, THAT'S IN
STATUTE TODAY. NO, UNDER 950 IS
A MISDEMEANOR. BUT THERE ARE
MANY WAYS THAT MOST OF THE
THEFTS WE'VE ALL SEEN ON THE
NEWS BECOME FELONIES. RIGHT. IT
IS NOT JUST ABOUT THE DOLLAR
AMOUNT. IT'S ABOUT THE CONDUCT
OF THE PERSON IN THE STORE. YOU
COULD STEAL A $2 CANDY BAR, BUT
IF YOU PULL A GUN ON THE STORE
CLERK, OR YOU PUNCH THEM IN THE
FACE ON YOUR WAY OUT THE DOOR,
YOU'VE NOW GOT A FELONY
CONSEQUENCE COMING. YOUR WAY.
PROBABLY MULTIPLE. ALL RIGHT. I
DO APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION,
SENATOR BRADFORD, YOU CAN GO.
SENATOR I THANK YOU, SHERIFF
COOPER STATED THAT THE OPPONENTS
WERE OPPOSED TO ANY CHANGES TO
PROP 47. I'M JUST CURIOUS, ARE
THERE SOME IMPROVEMENTS THAT
COULD BE MADE TO PROP 47 WITHOUT
THIS BALLOT INITIATIVE? FOR SOME
OF THE CHANGES YOU WOULD MAKE OR
SUGGEST? I THINK WE'VE JUST
DONE. YOU ALL HAVE JUST DONE
THAT WITH THE PACKAGE OF BILLS
YOU PASSED. AND WHAT I
APPRECIATED MOST ABOUT THAT
PACKAGE, IS IT WAS VERY BROAD
REACHING PUNISHMENT WAS
CONTEMPLATED. THE KINDS OF
OFFENSES YOU CAN CHARGE WAS
CONTEMPLATED. THOSE ARE FINE.
AND YOU LOOKED AT UPSTREAM
SOLUTIONS. WE HAD A BILL TO TRY
AND PUT MORE REGULATIONS ON
AMAZON AND FACEBOOK MARKETPLACE,
WHERE WE CAN SEE ALL THE STOLEN
GOODS GOING. WE HAD A BILL TO
INCREASE STAFFING IN THE BIG
STORES TO BECAUSE WE SEE IN
LOWE'S AND COSTCO, THERE'S NOT
AS MUCH THEFT BECAUSE THEY HAVE
PEOPLE WORKING IN THOSE STORES
VERSUS PLACES WHERE YOU'RE
PUSHING THE RED BUTTON FOR 30
MINUTES, HOPING YOU CAN GET YOUR
FACE CREAM. SO I THINK THAT THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY HAS DONE AN
INCREDIBLE JOB OF THINKING ABOUT
THE ISSUE FROM THE FRONT END OF
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE WHEN YOU
CHARGE A CASE TO THE MORE
PREVENTATIVE MEASURES WE CAN
TAKE, AS WELL AS HOW DO WE BRING
THOSE CONSEQUENCES IN COURT?
THANK YOU CHIEF, I'M SURE CHIEF,
I'VE BEEN LIKE MESSING UP ALL
DAY TODAY. IS THAT A PROMOTION?
YEAH. CHIEF OF THE ASSEMBLY?
YEAH. I WANTED TO TALK ABOUT.
THE DRUG SIDE AND ALSO THE, THE
PETTY THEFT FOR THE PRIORS.
LET'S START WITH WITH THE DRUG
SIDE. SO AS, AS OUR CHAIR
MENTIONED EARLIER, YOU KNOW,
I'VE SUPPORTED MEASURES TO PUSH
FORWARD MORE TREATMENT FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE REPEATEDLY
ARRESTED FOR DRUG RELATED CRIMES
OR, OR RETAIL THEFT CRIMES. FED
BY THEIR DRUG ADDICTION, BECAUSE
I DON'T THINK THE CURRENT SYSTEM
WITH VOLUNTARY IS WORKING. AND I
THINK YOU GO TO MOST CITIES AND
TALK A LOT OF COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA, AND YOU'LL SEE THAT
SOME YOU'LL HEAR THAT SAME,
PERCEPTION. SO I JUST WANT TO
ASK SO IS YOUR BELIEF THAT THAT,
INCENTIVIZED AND FORCED
TREATMENT SHOULD NEVER BE
UTILIZED AND DRUG TREATMENT
SHOULD ALWAYS BE 100% VOLUNTARY.
SO I DON'T REALLY DEAL IN
ABSOLUTES THAT WAY, I DO KNOW
THAT CHOSEN TREATMENT,
SELF-SELECTED TREATMENT HAS A
MUCH HIGHER SUCCESS RATE. IT
DOES THAT. THAT'S NOT MY OPINION.
THAT'S STUDIED, THERE ARE
MOMENTS OF COURSE, WHEN WE HAVE
SOMEONE'S ATTENTION WHERE WE
WANT TO PUT TREATMENT IN FRONT
OF THEM. ABSOLUTELY. AND COURTS
UP AND DOWN THE STATE. DO THAT
EVERY SINGLE DAY, AND DOES
EVERYBODY TAKE US UP ON IT EVERY
TIME WE OFFER NØ, I'M NOT GOING
TO SAY I'M NOT STANDING HERE TO
SAY MY BIGGEST POINT OF
CONTENTION WITH THE MEASURE IS
THAT IT MANDATES TREATMENT. MY
BIGGEST POINT OF CONTENTION IS
IT DOESN'T FUND IT. YEAH WELL, I
GUESS THAT THAT'S ONE OF THE
PUSHBACKS, TOO, BECAUSE FUNDING
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT, INPATIENT
TREATMENT IS VERY DIFFERENT THAN
OUTPATIENT. AND MANY TIMES
THAT'S WHAT YOU KNOW, DRUG
COURTS WERE ABOUT IS, YOU KNOW,
YOU GET PROBATION, YOU GO TO
YOUR, YOU KNOW, CLASSES OR AA OR
WHATEVER. YOU HAVE CLASSES, YOU
TAKE DRUG TESTS AND THEN IF YOU
SUCCEED, THEN YOU'RE, YOU'RE,
SENTENCE WILL BE REDUCED OR GO
AWAY. AND CONVERSELY, IF YOU
DON'T, THERE WOULD BE SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY. SO WHAT'S WHAT'S
WRONG WITH THAT? HAVING THOSE
THOSE OUTPATIENT OPPORTUNITIES
WHERE YOU INCENTIVIZE, YOU KNOW,
GOOD BEHAVIOR FOR A BETTER
OUTCOME FOR AN INDIVIDUAL? I
THINK OUTPATIENT TREATMENT IS
FANTASTIC. AND I THINK FOR SOME
PEOPLE IT WORKS VERY WELL. WELL,
DON'T YOU THINK THAT IF THIS
MEASURE PASSED THAT THE MAJORITY
OF THE PEOPLE THAT WERE ARRESTED
FOR, FOR REPEAT DRUG POSSESSION
AND USE, WHEN THEY GET
ADJUDICATED THROUGH THE COURT
SYSTEM WOULD HAVE THAT IT
WOULDN'T ALL BE INPATIENT, IT
WOULD BE OUTPATIENT DRUG
TREATMENT, WHICH ARE WHICH, MY
UNDERSTANDING, ARE PRETTY EMPTY
NOW IN THE LAST TEN YEARS AFTER
PROP 47. NO, THAT'S NOT TRUE. SO
THERE'S A SHORTAGE OF TREATMENT
BEDS, THERE'S A SHORTAGE OF
TREATMENT BEDS. THOSE ARE TWO
DIFFERENT THINGS. EXCUSE ME.
THERE'S A SHORTAGE OF TREATED
TREATMENT PROGRAMS EVERY SINGLE
DAY. WHEN YOU'RE IN COURT,
YOU'RE TRYING TO GET PEOPLE INTO
PROGRAMS, WHETHER YOU'RE A
PROSECUTOR OR A DEFENSE
ATTORNEY. THERE'S A PRETTY
SHARED AGREEMENT THAT WE WANT TO
GET PEOPLE INTO TREATMENT AS
OFTEN AS WE CAN. AND THERE ARE
NOT ENOUGH PROGRAMS AVAILABLE
ALMOST ANYWHERE IN THE STATE.
I'M NOT AWARE OF A COUNTY IN THE
STATE THAT THE MINUTE SOMEONE
SAYS THEY WANT OUTPATIENT
TREATMENT, THEY'RE ENROLLED IN
THAT TREATMENT. THEY'RE GETTING
TESTED, THEY'RE COMING BACK TO
COURT. I'D BE HAPPY TO SEE THAT.
I'D BE HAPPY TO SEE THAT IN ALL
58 COUNTIES IN THE STATE. BUT
PROP 36 IS NOT GOING TO CREATE
THAT. IT IS A WISH. IT IS A
HOPE. IT IS NOT A FUNDING PLAN
FOR MAKING THAT HAPPEN. YEAH. I
GUESS MAYBE I'LL JUST GO BACK TO
THIS ISSUE THAT I THINK SENATOR
NILO ASKED EARLIER WITH THE LOSS
OF DRUG COURTS. IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS WITH PROP 47 ON THE BOOKS.
SO WHEN I HEAR FROM OUR LOCAL,
DA'S OR LAW ENFORCEMENT, WELL,
BEFORE I, YOU KNOW, WAS ON
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE, CHAIRED
IT, THEY'VE SAID THAT
PARTICIPATION IN THE OUTPATIENT.
AND I 100% AGREE ON THE
INPATIENT. WE HAVE, YOU KNOW,
SEVERE SHORTAGE. BUT THE
OUTPATIENT, THEY SORRY THEY SAY
TO MY WATCH DISAGREES WITH HER.
YEAH. I'M NOT SURE WHO, THEY SAY
THAT THERE'S PLENTY OF SPACE IN
THESE OUTPATIENT DRUG REHAB
PROGRAMS THAT PEOPLE JUST AREN'T
PARTICIPATING ANYMORE. AFTER
PROP 47 WENT INTO EFFECT. DO YOU
THINK THAT'S ACCURATE OR
INACCURATE? THAT WAS NOT MY
EXPERIENCE FROM TEN YEARS IN THE
COURTS. NO TEN YEARS IN THE
COURTS. AFTER PROP 47 PASSED?
YES. BEFORE AND AFTER. OKAY.
IT'S ONLY BEEN TEN YEARS. SO
2011 TO 2020. OKAY YEAH. FAIR
ENOUGH. AND THEN BACK TO THE,
THE PETTY THEFT WITH A PRIOR. SO
WE DIDN'T ADDRESS THAT IN OUR
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE. WE WERE
ATTEMPTING TO DO SO IN A
COMPROMISE MEASURE TO GO TO THE
VOTERS THAT FELL APART AS WE
KNOW, DO YOU THINK THAT THERE IS
ANY FLAW IN CURRENT LAW BECAUSE
YOU SAY THAT WE CAN PROVIDE NEW
TOOLS AND WE ARTICULATE THAT.
AND YOU SUPPORTED SOME OF THESE
MEASURES. YOUR ORGANIZATION,
ACTUALLY, I THINK YOUR
ORGANIZATION DIDN'T SUPPORT A
LOT OF THEM. BUT DO YOU THINK
THAT THEY'RE ADEQUATE TOOLS ON
THE, IN THE, ON THE BOOKS TODAY
TO DEAL WITH PETTY THEFT WITH A
PRIOR? PERSONALLY, I DO. SO
PETTY THEFT CAN BE PUNISHED BY
UP TO SIX MONTHS IN JAIL FOR A
VERY SMALL AMOUNT, NO ONE REALLY
GETS SIX MONTHS IN JAIL FOR
PETTY THEFT. NOT THAT IT'S NOT
AVAILABLE TO US. IT WOULD BE A
RELATIVELY SIGNIFICANT SENTENCE
FOR SOMEONE TO SERVE. PEOPLE
SERVE LESS THAN THAT FOR
MISDEMEANOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
SO I THINK THAT THE IF WE'RE
LOOKING TO HAVE PUNISHMENT
CONSEQUENCES AVAILABLE TO US,
THEY DO EXIST. WHETHER THEY'RE
BEING IMPLEMENTED IN COUNTIES BY
BY PROSECUTORS AND JUDGES IS
ANOTHER QUESTION. WHETHER WE
WHEN WE'RE EVALUATING THOSE
CASES, THINK IT'S A NECESSARY OR
APPROPRIATE CONSEQUENCE.
OBVIOUSLY, WE'RE DECIDING MUCH
DIFFERENTLY UP AND DOWN THE
STATE. SO YOU SAY THAT TOOLS
EXIST. SO WHY DO YOU THINK THAT
PROSECUTORS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
AREN'T USING THOSE TOOLS IF THEY
EXIST? BECAUSE WE HEARD FROM
SHERIFF COOPER SAY THERE ARE NO
TOOLS, AND YOU'RE SAYING THERE
ARE TOOLS. SO WHY DO YOU THINK
THEY'RE NOT USING THE TOOLS THAT
YOU OUTLINED? WELL, I THINK YOU
NEED TO SEPARATE THOSE TWO. I
THINK PROSECUTORS UP AND DOWN
THE STATE ARE USING THE TOOLS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO THEM. WE
HAVE ALMOST TWO DOZEN THEFT
OFFENSES WE CAN CHARGE, AND I
THINK THEY ARE BEING USED. IF
YOU LOOK, I JUST LOOKED AT LA
COUNTY'S NUMBER OF CHARGING OVER
90% OF THE CASES THAT ARE
BROUGHT TO THEM ON THIS THEFT.
WHAT IS NOT HAPPENING IS THE
ARREST. THERE'S A VERY LOW
ARREST RATE FOR THEFT, 8%. IF
I'VE GOT A 92% SHOT OF RUNNING
INTO THE STORE AND RUNNING OUT
UNDETECTED, AND THAT'S THAT'S
MOTIVATING ME, THERE'S VERY
LITTLE DETERRENT THERE. IT IS
NOT ABOUT WHETHER THIS IS MY
SECOND OR THIRD. AND NOW I'M
GOING TO GET A YEAR IN JAIL, OR
I'M GOING TO GET A STATE PRISON
SENTENCE. THAT IS JUST NOT THE
WAY THAT THE THAT THE DECISION
MAKING HAPPENS AROUND THAT KIND
OF ACTIVITY. SO WHY DO YOU THINK
ARRESTS ARE NOT BEING MADE?
WELL, YOU HAD A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIAL HERE WHO EXPLAINED TO
YOU THAT HE DOESN'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES. I THINK THAT THERE'S
ALSO BEEN LIKE AN UNWILLINGNESS
TO ENFORCE MISDEMEANOR LAWS IN
THIS STATE SINCE PROP 47 PASSED
SINCE 2014. THOSE DATA ARE
AVAILABLE TO YOU CAN LOOK AND
SEE WHAT THE ARREST RATE HAS
BEEN ON MISDEMEANOR AND FELONY
OFFENSES. IT HAS GONE OFF A
CLIFF. IT HAS DROPPED INTO A
DITCH. OKAY. THANK YOU, SENATOR
NEIL, I'M. THANK YOU. OH, YEAH,
I HEARD THANK YOU. AND I WALKED
AWAY. OR ANYONE ELSE WHO WANTS
TO ADDRESS THIS. IS THERE A
CONNECTION BETWEEN DRUG
ADDICTION AND RETAIL THEFT, I'M
SURE THAT THERE IS. I WOULDN'T
SAY THAT. I THINK THAT THAT'S
THE BIGGEST DRIVING FORCE, MORE
OF WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN THE
KINDS OF ACTIVITY COMMUNITY
MEMBERS COME FORWARD AND ARE SO
DISTRESSED BY WHEN WE SEE, YOU
KNOW, CLOTHING TURNSTILES BEING
TURNED OVER AND CABINETS BEING
SMASHED, MUCH MORE OF THAT.
WE'RE LEARNING FROM THE CHP
INVESTIGATIONS AND OTHER REALLY
IS DRIVEN BY CALLS FROM A FEW
PEOPLE TO SAY GO AND TAKE AS
MUCH OF THESE KINDS OF PRODUCTS
AS YOU CAN. I'LL GIVE YOU $200
AND BRING THEM TO ME, AND THEN
THAT'S BEING RESOLD IN THE
ONLINE AND OTHER MARKETPLACES.
THAT SEEMS TO BE THE BIGGEST
DRIVER OF IT. BUT ARE THERE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE A DRUG ADDICTION
ISSUE OR A DRUG USE ISSUE THAT
STEAL FOR THE SUSTENANCE AROUND
THAT? SURE. I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE NUMBERS ARE. SO THERE IS A
CONNECTION. IT'S JUST AN ISSUE
OF TO WHAT EXTENT NOW,
PROPOSITION 47 WAS PASSED IN
2014. YES. AND DRUG COURT WAS
UTILIZED TO A SIGNIFICANTLY
GREATER EXTENT PRIOR TO THAT
THAN SINCE THAT NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, HOUSING FIRST WAS
ADOPTED IN CALIFORNIA AS AN
OFFICIAL POLICY FOR HOMELESSNESS,
MEANING THAT SHELTER CAN BE
PROVIDED ONLY WITH TREATMENT
SERVICES BEING OPTIONAL, BOTH
MENTAL AS WELL AS DRUG ADDICTION,
SINCE 2016, HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA HAS EXPLODED AND,
UNTREATED DRUG ADDICTION AMONG
HOMELESS PEOPLE HAS BEEN PART OF
THAT EXPLOSION. SO WE HAVE TWO
SITUATIONS. PROPOSITION 47 AND
HOUSING FIRST, CREATING A MORE
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM WITH REGARD
TO DRUG ADDICTION THAN WE HAD
BEFORE, LARGELY BECAUSE THERE
ISN'T A MECHANISM FOR
INCENTIVIZING IT OR FORCING IT.
WHATEVER TERM YOU WANT TO USE,
WOULD YOU HAVE A REACTION TO
THAT PHENOMENA? CAN YOU POSE ME
A QUESTION YOU'RE ASKING? IS
THERE A CONNECTION? WE'VE GONE
DOWN THE ROAD OF, NOT DOING OUR
BEST TO INCENTIVIZE OR FORCE
DRUG TREATMENT, BOTH BY
DECRIMINALIZATION OF PROPOSITION
47, WHICH PROVIDE THE PROVIDED
THE INCENTIVE FOR DRUG COURT
BEFORE AS WELL AS THE HOMELESS
POLICY OF NOT TRYING TO
INCENTIVIZE DRUG TREATMENT, AS
PART OF, HOUSING FOR
HOMELESSNESS. BOTH OF THOSE
ISSUES, COINCIDING WITH A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
HOMELESSNESS AND DRUG ADDICTION
AMONG HOMELESS PEOPLE, DON'T YOU
THINK THAT, A SYSTEM THAT WOULD
MORE EFFECTIVELY INCENTIVIZE OR
FORCE TREATMENT WOULD BE A
BETTER WAY OF TRYING TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE AND BRINGING IT BACK
INTO CONTROL AS THE NUMBERS THAT
EXISTED BEFORE PROPOSITION 47
MIGHT SUGGEST. SO I THINK WHAT I
WOULD DO IN RESPONSE TO THIS
QUESTION IS LOOK AT THE HISTORY
OF OUR RESPONSE TO DRUG USE AND
DRUG SALES IN THIS STATE. WE CAN
LOOK BACK AT THE 80S AND 90S AND
EARLY 2000, WHEN WE HAD VERY
STRICT PUNISHMENTS FOR DRUGS,
POSSESSION, USE, SALES. AND THEN
WE CAN LOOK POST 2014 WHERE WE
ADDRESSED SOME OF THE USE
ISSUES. DRUG USE WAS HIGHER AND
THEN IN THAT TIME THAN IT IS IN
THE POST PROP 47 PERIOD. I THINK
THAT THE ISSUE THAT GETS BROUGHT
UP AROUND DRUG COURT IS THAT
DRUG COURT USED TO BE BASED ON
THE FACT THAT IT WAS A FELONY,
THAT POSSESSION OF DRUGS, ALL OF
THE HARD DRUGS WAS A FELONY. AND
THAT POST PROP 47, OBVIOUSLY,
THAT THEY ARE MISDEMEANORS AND
THE SUGGESTION THAT THEN
THEREFORE PEOPLE DON'T TAKE
TREATMENT BECAUSE IT'S A
MISDEMEANOR INSTEAD OF A FELONY,
THAT DOESN'T REALLY MESH FOR ME
IN TERMS OF WHY PEOPLE WOULD OR
WOULDN'T GET INTO TREATMENT
AGAIN ON A MISDEMEANOR. LET'S
REMEMBER, A PERSON CAN STILL
SERVE UP TO A YEAR IN COUNTY
JAIL FOR DRUG POSSESSION. THAT
IS A SIGNIFICANT PUNISHMENT FOR
THE INDIVIDUAL SERVING IT, EVEN
IF IT'S US GIVING IT OUT MAY NOT
FEEL THAT THAT'S A SUBSTANTIAL.
SO I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE
CHANGE IN THE LAW, HAD ANYTHING
TO DO WITH DRUG USE. I THINK
WHAT HAS CHANGED AROUND DRUG USE
IS THE KINDS OF DRUGS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE. FENTANYL DID NOT
EXIST PRE 2014 OR EVEN RIGHT
AFTER. RIGHT. THIS IS A NEW
PHENOMENON, THERE'S FURTHER
EVIDENCE WHEN WE LOOK TO OTHER
STATES, YOU CAN LOOK AT A PLACE
LIKE PENNSYLVANIA THAT HAS NOT
PASSED ANYTHING SIMILAR TO PROP
47, OR TRIED TO CHANGE THE WAY
THEY HANDLE THOSE DRUG CASES,
AND THEY HAVE HAD THE EXACT SAME
CHALLENGES WE'RE HAVING WITH
FENTANYL BECAUSE OF THE
SUBSTANCE IT IS AND THE AND THE
ADDICTIVE NATURE OF IT. SO I
THINK IT IS MUCH MORE CORRELATED
TO THE SUBSTANCES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE. THE NEWNESS OF THEM
AND OUR ABILITY TO FIND
STRATEGIES AROUND IT, THAN IT IS
THAT WE REDUCE THE PUNISHMENT TO
A MISDEMEANOR. SO YOU BELIEVE
THAT THE EXPLOSION IN THE
HOMELESSNESS NUMBERS, SINCE
THOSE TWO POLICIES WERE ADOPTED,
TO THE EXTENT THAT DRUG
ADDICTION IS PART OF THE
HOMELESSNESS ISSUE, IS DRIVEN BY
A DIFFERENT ARRAY OF DRUGS THAT
ARE ON THE MARKET. NO, I DON'T
BELIEVE HOMELESSNESS IS DRIVEN
BY THAT. I BELIEVE HOMELESSNESS
IS DRIVEN BY OUR REAL ESTATE
MARKET. OH, OKAY. A LOT OF
PEOPLE WOULD DISAGREE WITH YOU
ON THAT. IT COULD, BUT I THINK
THAT WE CAN SEE THE STUDIES THAT
WILL SHOW YOU FOR EVERY $100
INCREASE IN RENT, THE NUMBERS OF
PEOPLE THAT FALL OUT OF HOUSING
AND INTO HOMELESSNESS, IT'S A
MUCH HIGHER PREDICTOR OF
HOMELESSNESS IS THE COST OF
HOUSING THAN IT IS THE
AVAILABILITY OF DRUGS. AND YOU
DENY THAT DRUG ADDICTION,
UNTREATED DRUG ADDICTION AND
MENTAL ILLNESS IS NOT A MAJOR
PART OF HOMELESSNESS. I THINK IT
IS PRESENT IN PEOPLE THAT ARE
UNHOUSED. I DON'T KNOW THAT IT
IS WHAT CAUSES HOMELESSNESS. I
DON'T THINK ANY OF US COULD
POINT TO ANY INFORMATION IN THAT
REGARD. IT'S QUITE A DEBATE
GOING ON OUTSIDE THIS CHAMBER ON
THAT PARTICULAR POINT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU. CHAIR, I HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS. WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT
PEOPLE VOLUNTEERING FOR
TREATMENT. CAN YOU GIVE US
EXAMPLES OF THOSE WHO VOLUNTEER
FOR TREATMENT? WHO WHO WOULD
THAT BE AND WHAT TREATMENT? A
LOT OF PEOPLE VOLUNTEER FOR
TREATMENT RATHER THAN JAIL TIME.
ABSOLUTELY. ALL THE TIME IN
COURTS UP AND DOWN THE STATE.
OKAY. SO GIVE ME AN EXAMPLE. IS
THAT SOMEBODY I'M GOING TO SEE
ON THE STREET THAT'S, YOU KNOW,
BEEN THERE FOR WEEKS, MONTHS OR
IS THAT SOMEBODY THAT JUST GOT
INTRODUCED TO DRUGS. LIKE WHAT?
WHAT'S AN EXAMPLE OF THAT? I'M
JUST HEARING SOMEBODY IS
VOLUNTEERING. THAT'S NOT REALLY
SAYING MUCH. I THINK THAT COULD
LOOK A LOT OF DIFFERENT WAYS,
YOU WILL HAVE INDIVIDUALS THAT
COME IN THAT ARE JUST STARTED
USING DRUGS WHERE TREATMENT IS A
MUCH EASIER OFF RAMP FOR THEM.
THEY SAY, GREAT, I'LL TAKE IT IN
THAT MOMENT. YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO
ARE ON THEIR NINTH OR 10TH TIME
THROUGH THE COURT SYSTEM AND
REALIZING JAIL IS NOT DEALING
WITH THE ISSUE THAT THEY HAVE,
AND MAYBE TREATMENT WOULD BE A
BETTER PATH. I THINK YOU HAVE
EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN THERE AND
HOW LONG DOES A TREATMENT LAST?
WELL, THAT VARIES BY THE CASE
THAT'S IN FRONT OF THE COURT AND
WHAT THE PROSECUTOR AND DEFENSE
CAN AGREE TO, OR WHAT THE JUDGE
IMPOSES. AND WHAT ARE WE TALKING
TWO DAYS? WE'RE TALKING A WEEK.
WHAT KIND OF TREATMENT? I'M
UNAWARE OF ANY TWO DAY DRUG
TREATMENT PROGRAMS. I'M NOT
EITHER. BUT I WANT TO HEAR
SOMETHING. THE SHERIFF WAS UP
HERE. HE COULDN'T ANSWER IT, BUT
I WAS HOPING MAYBE YOU CAN AT
LEAST GIVE US AN IDEA. ARE WE
LOOKING AT, LIKE, A YEAR
TREATMENT? TWO YEAR TREATMENT?
WELL, IT'S GOING TO VARY AS YOU
KNOW, HAVING BEEN IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT, WE WILL COME TO THE
PERSON AND SAY ALL RIGHT, YOU
HAVE A MISDEMEANOR CASE OR YOU
HAVE A FELONY CASE. WE'D LIKE TO
OFFER YOU TREATMENT INSTEAD OF
JAIL TIME. ARE YOU INTERESTED IN
THAT? YES, I AM, AND THEN IN OUR
BEST WORK, WE WILL BRING IN A
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL WHO ACTUALLY
KNOWS WHAT THE INDIVIDUAL IS
STRUGGLING WITH. BECAUSE I, AS
SOMEBODY WHO WENT TO LAW SCHOOL,
DO NOT KNOW HOW TO DIAGNOSE DRUG
ADDICTION OR DRUG TREATMENT.
WHEN WE BRING IN THOSE
PROFESSIONALS, THEY WILL TELL US
THIS PERSON NEEDS AN INPATIENT
PROGRAM BECAUSE THEIR ADDICTION
IS SO SEVERE THAT AN OUTPATIENT
PROGRAM WON'T SUPPORT THEM. THIS
INDIVIDUAL WILL DO FINE IN AN
OUTPATIENT PROGRAM. WE SHOULD
LOOK AT A THREE MONTH AND COME
BACK IN THREE MONTHS AND CHECK
IN OR A SIX MONTH. IT WILL VARY
AND BE TAILORED TO THE PERSON'S
NEEDS AND WHAT RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE IN THAT COUNTY. AND
DID YOU FIND THAT SOME PEOPLE
WOULD RATHER DO THE TIME THAN
THE TREATMENT, BECAUSE THE
TREATMENT TOOK LONGER THAN THE
TIME THEY WOULD HAVE TO PUT IN?
YES. I SAW A LOT OF PEOPLE
CHOOSE JAIL BECAUSE TREATMENT
WAS SO INDEFINITELY UNAVAILABLE.
AND THEN YOU HAD MENTIONED THAT
THEY'D BE DOING A YEAR. WOULD
THEY ACTUALLY BE DOING A YEAR,
OR WOULD IT BE LIKE SIX MONTHS?
FOUR MONTHS? IT VARIES, RIGHT?
IT VARIES BY THE INDIVIDUAL, THE
SEVERITY OF THE CRIME. THEY
HAVE, THE SEVERITY OF THEIR DRUG
USE ISSUE. IT WOULD BE DIFFERENT
IN EACH CASE. AND THEN JUST ONE
LAST THING YOU TALKED ABOUT HOW
ARRESTS. MISDEMEANOR ARRESTS HAD
DROPPED DRASTICALLY. AND I WANT
TO SAY 8% WAS SOMETHING I DON'T
KNOW. I COULD HAVE HAD THAT
MIXED UP, DO YOU KNOW WHY THE
LACK OF ARREST IS HAPPENING WITH
MISDEMEANORS? I WON'T I, I DON'T
KNOW IF IT'S THE SAME ACROSS THE
STATE. WE HEARD THE SACRAMENTO
SHERIFF SAY THAT HE DOES NOT
HAVE ADEQUATE RESOURCES TO
ENFORCE THE LAW. I KNOW THAT
WHEN PROP 47 PASSED, MANY LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS SAID THEY
WERE NOT GOING TO BOTHER WITH
MISDEMEANORS. I THINK IT'S
PROBABLY A WHOLE RANGE OF THINGS
THAT ARE HAPPENING. THEY'RE BOTH
RESOURCES AND SORT OF A
DISAGREEMENT ABOUT THE WAY THE
STATE HAS MOVED ON THESE ISSUES.
BUT THE ARREST RATE CURRENTLY
FOR PROPERTY CRIME IS 8% ACROSS
THE STATE. SO IT'S NOT JUST A
SACRAMENTO ISSUE, OKAY. AND JUST
JUST SO EVERYBODY IS AWARE AGAIN,
MISDEMEANORS HAVE TO BE
COMMITTED IN THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S PRESENCE. SO NOW
AS A LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
SHOWING UP TO A SCENE, THEY HAVE
TO HAVE THAT PERSON THAT
WITNESSED IT MAKE THE ARREST,
MAKING THEM ULTIMATELY THE BAD
GUY, WHICH A LOT OF PEOPLE
OBVIOUSLY AREN'T DOING. SO THESE
MISDEMEANOR ARRESTS AREN'T BEING
BEING MADE. I'M SURE SOME PEOPLE
HAVE GONE TO RETAIL STORES AND
HAVE ACTUALLY WITNESSED A THEFT
HAPPENING, BUT THEY'RE NOT ALL
WILLING TO SIGN A CITIZEN'S
ARREST. AND I DON'T BLAME THEM
EITHER, BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT
TO GET INVOLVED OR THEY DON'T
WANT TO BECOME VICTIMIZED LATER
DOWN THE ROAD. SO I THINK THAT
ATTRIBUTES TO WHY THESE
MISDEMEANOR ARRESTS HAVE
DROPPED, BECAUSE IT'S NOT THAT
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT AREN'T DOING
THEIR JOB, IT'S JUST THAT IT HAS
TO NOW BE COMMITTED IN THEIR
PRESENCE FOR IT TO HAPPEN WHERE
AS OPPOSED TO IT USED TO BE A
FELONY, THEY CAN INVESTIGATE AND
MAKE THE ARREST. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I DO APPRECIATE ALL
YOUR COMMENTARY. I DO JUST WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT, YOU KNOW, A COUPLE
OF THINGS YOU PROVIDE A LOT OF
DATA WHICH WAS NOT PREVIOUSLY
PROVIDED. AND I DO APPRECIATE
THAT. AND I THINK THAT DATA
SPEAKS FOR ITSELF. RIGHT. AND
IT'S UNIFORMLY GATHERED, AND,
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU MENTIONED
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES, AGAIN,
IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE FACT THAT IT IS
CLEARLY PROVEN, ESPECIALLY AS A
PERSON IN SOCIAL WORK, THAT
TREATMENT FOR EXAMPLE, WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT IT, IT IS THE ONE
TIME DRUG USER. SO IT COULD BE A
HIGH SCHOOLER OR A COLLEGE KID
THAT GOES TO A PARTY, IS HANDED
SOMETHING AND SAYS, WHY NOT? YOU
ONLY LIVE ONCE OR WHEN IN VEGAS.
WHATEVER THE CASE IS, THEY DO IT
ONCE AND THEY COULD POTENTIALLY
DIE FROM THAT PARTICULAR, DRUG
THAT THEY INGESTED, THAT'S ONE
PIECE. AND THEN THERE IS THE
FREQUENT, TRUE ADDICT THAT IS
LOOKING FOR THEIR HIGH EVERY SO
OFTEN, EVERY FEW HOURS, EVERY
FEW DAYS, WHATEVER THE CASE MAY
BE, AND I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
THE DISCREPANCY THERE RIGHT. AND
A LOT OF WHAT WE HAVE FOCUSED ON
AND JUST AS CHAIR OF PUBLIC
SAFETY, I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THIS
TO THE PUBLIC BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT IS
THAT THERE ARE TWO TYPES OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE TEND TO HAVE
TO FOCUS ON WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT LAW ENFORCEMENT. ONE IS
THE DRUG USER AND ONE IS THE
DRUG DEALER. BOTH CRIMES. RIGHT?
PURCHASING DRUGS OR TAKING DRUGS
AND SO FORTH IS ILLEGAL,
ESPECIALLY ALL OF THESE ILLEGAL
SUBSTANCES THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT, ESPECIALLY THE MOST
DEADLY FENTANYL THAT WE ARE
SEEING, AND, AND MUCH MORE. AND
THEN IT'S THE DRUG DEALER. AND
SOMETIMES THAT DRUG DEALER IS,
COMPLETELY UNAWARE OF WHAT THEY
ARE DOING IN THE SENSE OF WHAT
IS IN THE MIXTURE, WHAT IS IN
THE COMPOUND, AND THEY'RE
HANDING IT OUT AS PARTY FAVORS
OR WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE, AND
NOT TRULY A DRUG DEALER, BUT
JUST A FRIEND WHO WANTED TO HAVE
A GOOD TIME WITH OTHER FRIENDS,
AND I REALLY WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THIS BECAUSE WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TREATMENT, IT VARIES BASED
ON THE PATIENT AND THE CLIENT,
IT ALSO VARIES VERY MUCH ON THE
PROBLEM. RIGHT. AND SO I
PERSONALLY BELIEVE THAT LAWS
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
PUBLIC INPUT, MORE STAKEHOLDERS,
MORE DISCUSSION. AND AGAIN, WE
NEED TO BE VERY COGNIZANT OF HOW
IMPORTANT AND HOW LAWS REALLY DO
AFFECT LIVES, ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO PUBLIC SAFETY, BOTH
POSITIVELY AND NEGATIVELY.
RIGHT. AND I AM A TRUE BELIEVER
OF, YOU KNOW, RULE OF LAW AND
HAVING ENFORCEMENT AND MAKING
SURE PEOPLE ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE, BUT THEN ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
RIGHT TOOLS AND RESOURCES TO
PROVIDE THE SUPPORT THAT SOCIETY
NEEDS, TO THE COMMENT EARLIER, I
WILL SAY THAT I DO BELIEVE
HOUSING AND QUALITY OF LIFE
ISSUES ARE ONE OF THE BIGGEST
FACTORS THAT ARE, IN MY OPINION,
PLAGUING CALIFORNIANS, AND IN IN
MY DISTRICT, AN AVERAGE HOME
COSTS $1.5 MILLION. SO YOU KNOW,
HOW ARE PEOPLE REALLY SURVIVING?
SO I REALLY WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT, THAT THERE ARE MANY OTHER
ISSUES THAT REALLY PLAGUE
PEOPLE'S QUALITY OF LIFE. AND
OBVIOUSLY PUBLIC SAFETY IS A BIG,
YOU KNOW, PIECE OF THAT. BUT I
DO APPRECIATE YOU COMING WITH
FACTS. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH. MY
PLEASURE. OUR NEXT PRESENTER IS
GOING TO BE AGAIN, I'M GOING TO
APOLOGIZE FOR THE NAME CHARLES
VIGNOLA, PUBLIC POLICY AND
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT MANAGER, LA
REGIONAL REENTRY PARTNERSHIP.
THANK YOU. YES, THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THAT WAS CLOSE. THE G IS
SILENT ITALIANS. MY GRANDFATHER
WOULD KILL ME IF I DIDN'T
CORRECT THAT. GOOD MORNING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND SENATORS OF
THE JOINT PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. AS MENTIONED, MY NAME
IS CHARLES VIGNOLA. I'M THE
PUBLIC POLICY AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT MANAGER FOR THE LOS
ANGELES REENTRY REGIONAL REENTRY
PARTNERSHIP, AND WE'RE HERE TO
DISCUSS WHAT WE SEE AS THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT DANGERS OF
PROPOSITION 36, SPECIFICALLY
WITH REGARD TO HOW CRUCIAL
COMMUNITY SAFETY AND WELL-BEING
SERVICES STAND TO BE AFFECTED.
IF THIS PROPOSITION PASSES.
SINCE 2015, SERVICE PROVIDERS
ACROSS THE STATE HAVE UTILIZED
FUNDS AND RESOURCES ALLOCATED BY
PROPOSITION 47. CALIFORNIA
VOTERS EMBRACED A VISION THAT
SOUGHT TO EMPOWER LOCALITIES AND
COMMUNITIES TO INVEST IN UNIQUE
PROGRAMING AND INFRASTRUCTURE TO
HELP THOSE MOST VULNERABLE. THIS
FUNDING GOES TO PROGRAMS THAT
HAVE PROVIDED HOUSING SERVICES,
MENTAL HEALTH CARE, SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER TREATMENT PROGRAMS
AND JOB TRAINING FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN ARRESTED OR
INCARCERATED, WHICH MAKES OUR
COMMUNITIES HEALTHY AND MORE
STABLE. OVER THE PAST DECADE,
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
DIVERSION AND REENTRY, OR R,
WHICH LA HELPED ESTABLISH IN
2015, HAVE IMPLEMENTED NOVEL
APPROACHES TO COMMUNITY
SUPPORTED CARE BEDS AND MENTAL
AND PHYSICAL HEALTH SUPPORT FOR
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS. THESE
PROGRAMS INCLUDE PROJECTS LIKE
PROJECT IMPACT, WHICH IS
DESIGNED BY THE LOS ANGELES
MAYOR'S OFFICE OF REENTRY, WHICH
PROVIDES EMPLOYMENT, BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH, AND LEGAL SERVICES TO
IMPROVE EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES AND
REDUCE FUTURE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM INVOLVEMENT FOR MEN OF
COLOR. ANOTHER PROGRAM, THE LA
COUNTY REENTRY INTEGRATED
SERVICES PROJECT, REENTRY
INTENSIVE CASE MANAGEMENT
SERVICES, OR CMS, LINKS PEOPLE
WITH PRIOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM INVOLVEMENT TO COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS AIMED AT
IMPROVING THEIR WELL-BEING AND
KEEPING THEM OUT OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. TOGETHER, THESE
AND OTHER PROGRAMS HAVE HELPED
MOVE THOUSANDS OF INDIVIDUALS
INTO COMMUNITY SUPPORTED
PROGRAMS, DELIVERING EXTREMELY
POSITIVE OUTCOMES FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES. UNFORTUNATELY
PROPOSITION 36 THREATENS TO UNDO
THIS PROGRESS BY GUTTING FUNDING
FOR THESE SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS,
KEEPING AN INDIVIDUAL IN
CALIFORNIA INCARCERATED IS
EXPENSIVE, AND AS NOTED, CAN
COST UPWARDS OF $130,000 PER
YEAR IN A STATE PRISON. IF
PROPOSITION 36 WERE TO PASS. THE
LAW STATED THAT THE ESTIMATES
BOTH THE NUMBER OF INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS WOULD INCREASE AND
SO WOULD THE NEEDED SUPPORT
STAFF TO HANDLE THESE NEW
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS,
INCLUDING PRISON STAFF, JAIL
STAFF, AND COURT STAFF. IN A
TIME WHEN THE BUDGET IS ALREADY
A CHALLENGE TO BALANCE, WHY
WOULD WE TAKE MONEY AWAY FROM
PROVEN DIVERSION AND REENTRY
PROGRAMS AND SPEND EVEN MORE TO
LOCK PEOPLE UP? THESE FUNDS WILL
BE SPENT IN ONE OF TWO WAYS,
EITHER BY INVESTING IN EFFECTIVE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES TO GET FOLKS
THAT THAT. SORRY TO GET FOLKS
THE HELP THEY TRULY AND
SUCCESSFULLY NEED TO INTEGRATE
INTO SOCIETY, AS WE HAVE FOR THE
PAST DECADE, OR BY LOCKING FOLKS
UP AND NOT TAKING PROACTIVE
STEPS TO BRING THEM BACK TO
THEIR HOMES, FAMILIES, AND
COMMUNITIES, SERVICE PROVIDERS
ARE ABLE TO TAKE ALREADY
EARMARKED FUNDS AND
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE PEOPLE'S
LIVES FOR THE BETTER. RATHER
THAN FUNDING A SYSTEM WITH THE
SOLE INTENTION OF PUNISHING THE
INCARCERATED POPULATION WITHOUT
HELPING REHABILITATE THEM FOR
NEARLY A DECADE, SERVICE
PROVIDERS HAVE BEEN WORKING TO
UNDERSTAND THE COMPLEX
CONTRACTING AND GRANT
REQUIREMENTS IN ORDER TO HELP
THOUSANDS OF JUSTICE IMPACTED
INDIVIDUALS RETURN TO THEIR
FAMILIES, SECURE STABLE HOUSING,
AND FIND GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT, AS
WELL AS CONTRIBUTE MEANINGFULLY
TO SOCIETY. THIS PROGRESS WOULD
BE IMPOSSIBLE IF WE CHOOSE TO
INVEST IN MORE JAILS INSTEAD OF
EXPANDING DIVERSION AND REENTRY
SERVICES. PROPOSITION 36 IS A
REGRESSIVE STEP THAT SACRIFICES
THE LONG TERM ACHIEVED PROGRESS
OF OUR NETWORK OF 500 SERVICE
PROVIDERS FOR SHORT TERM AND
COSTLY CHANGES AT THE EXPENSE OF
OUR TAXPAYERS, OUR COMMUNITIES,
AND THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. MONEY SPENT ON
PRISONS DOES NOT HELP
REHABILITATE INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE COMMITTED CRIMES, NOR DOES
IT BENEFIT THE COMMUNITIES WHO
ARE MOST IMPACTED BY
OVERPOLICING, SENDING MORE LOW
LEVEL OFFENDERS TO JAILS AND
PRISONS ONLY SERVES TO FURTHER
DISENFRANCHIZE THEM, CREATING A
FEEDBACK LOOP THAT BARS THEM
FROM RECEIVING THE CARE AND
SERVICES NEEDED TO SUCCESSFULLY
RETURN HOME TO THEIR COMMUNITIES.
PROPOSITION 36 IS NOT AN
INVESTMENT IN THE PEOPLE WHO
NEED IT MOST, BUT RATHER AN
INVESTMENT IN THE WALLS THAT
KEEP THEM FROM BEING THE PEOPLE
WE KNOW THEY CAN BE. I AM HERE
ON BEHALF OF MORE THAN 500
SERVICE PROVIDERS IN THE LOS
ANGELES REGIONAL REENTRY
PARTNERSHIP NETWORK ACROSS THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
STAND STEADFAST WITH THE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HAVE HELPED WORK TIRELESSLY TO
IMPLEMENT SUCCESSFUL, FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE AND PRACTICAL
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES TO THE
JUSTICE IMPACTED COMMUNITY. AND
I URGE YOU TO DO THE SAME. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. SEEING
NO COMMENTS, WE'LL GO ON TO OUR
NEXT SPEAKER, TANISHA HOLLINS,
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE. GOOD MORNING TO THE
COMMITTEE AGAIN. MY NAME IS
TANISHA HOLLINS. I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE. I'M ALSO A SURVIVOR OF
A CRIME. I'VE LOST TWO BROTHERS
TO HOMICIDE. ONE OF MY BROTHERS
STRUGGLED WITH ADDICTION AND WAS
ACTUALLY INTRODUCED TO DRUGS
WHILE INCARCERATED. I AM A
FRIEND WHO HAS RECENTLY IN THE
LAST 24 MONTHS, HELPED THREE OF
MY FRIENDS BURY THEIR CHILDREN
TO FENTANYL OVERDOSES. FIRST
TIME USERS BETWEEN THE AGES OF
19 AND 27 YEARS OLD. I REPRESENT
A NETWORK OF CRIME SURVIVORS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA, OVER
50,000 FROM UNDERREPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE BEEN USING
THEIR VOICES TO CALL FOR
SOLUTIONS AROUND PUBLIC SAFETY.
BECAUSE VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS
KNOW MORE ABOUT WHAT IT TAKES TO
MAKE COMMUNITIES SAFE THAN
ANYONE ELSE, BECAUSE THEY HAVE
HAD TO STRUGGLE WITH BEING
UNSAFE AND HAVING TO PICK UP
THEIR LIVES AND RECOVER MOSTLY
ON THEIR OWN WITH VERY LITTLE
SUPPORT. I APPRECIATE ALL OF THE
COMMENTS THAT CAME BEFORE ME TO
GIVE CONTEXT FOR WHAT PROP 36 IS
AND ISN'T, AND I WON'T SPEND
MUCH TIME REHASHING THINGS THAT
YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD. BUT I DO
WANT TO EMPHASIZE HOW IMPORTANT
IT IS FOR US TO FOCUS ON
SOLUTIONS RIGHT NOW. AND I DO
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE SOLUTION
SHOULD ONLY INCREASE ACCESS.
THEY SHOULD ONLY INCREASE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FOLKS TO GET
DIRECT SERVICES. THEY SHOULD
ONLY EXPAND THE RESOURCES
SPECIFICALLY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
AND IF WE HEAR THAT AN
INITIATIVE POSES A THREAT TO OUR
ABILITY TO DO THAT, WE SHOULD
TAKE IT SERIOUSLY. WE SHOULD
TAKE IT SERIOUSLY BECAUSE IT
WILL DO THE EXACT OPPOSITE OF
INCREASED PUBLIC SAFETY. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT EVERYONE WHO
STOOD HERE HAS A ROLE IN HOW
PUBLIC SAFETY IS IMPLEMENTED,
BOTH AT THE STATE AND IN THE
COUNTY AND LOCAL LEVEL. WE
SHOULD TAKE THAT RESPONSIBILITY
SERIOUSLY BY THINKING ABOUT
EXACTLY WHY THE TOOLS THAT WE
HAVE AT OUR DISPOSAL ARE NOT
BEING UTILIZED THE WAY THEY
SHOULD BE TO INCREASE PUBLIC
SAFETY, AND THAT WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT MEASURES THAT ARE
GOING TO SUPPORT US BEING ABLE
TO EFFECTIVELY DELIVER PUBLIC
SAFETY NOW. SO THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE RELIEF. I WANT TO ALSO
NAME THAT PROP 47 SAVINGS LAW IS
AN EXAMPLE OF THE TYPE OF
PROGRAMING THAT PROP 47 SAVINGS
HAS DIRECTED TO. WE'VE ALSO BEEN
ABLE TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
TRAUMA RECOVERY CENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA FROM 14 TO 22. THAT
DEALS WITH AN IMMEDIATE DRIVER
OF CRIME UNADDRESSED TRAUMA
VICTIMIZATION, THE NEED FOR
ONGOING LONG TERM SUPPORT,
SOCIAL SERVICES, MENTAL HEALTH
THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF THINGS
THAT WE WANT TO SEE AVAILABLE TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF CRIME. SAME
WITH ADDICTION TREATMENT. I KNOW
FROM LIVED EXPERIENCE THE NUMBER
OF TIMES THAT MY BROTHER WAS
OFFERED TREATMENT, AND TREATMENT
WAS NOT AVAILABLE ON DEMAND FOR
HIM. THAT WAS A DRIVER OF HIS
ADDICTION AND ONE OF THE MAIN
CAUSES OF HIS LOSS OF LIFE. HE
LOST HIS LIFE IN 2017 AT THE
SAME SITE WHERE HE WOULD GO
EVERY DAY TO GET HIGH, AND HE
WAS A VICTIM OF A HOMICIDE THAT
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH HIS
ADDICTION. WE KNOW THAT PUBLIC
SAFETY REQUIRES MORE THAN US
RELYING ON LAW ENFORCEMENT. MUCH
OF WHAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT TODAY
ARE ALSO PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES,
AND I WOULD HAVE LOVED TO HEAR
FROM A PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL ABOUT THE EXACT
NEEDS OF THE POPULATIONS WHO
STRUGGLE WITH ADDICTION. YOU
HAVE PEOPLE HERE WHO HAVE
REPRESENTED INTEREST IN GETTING
FOLKS SAFE, REENTRY AND GETTING
THEM ACCESS TO HOUSING, LONG
TERM SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IS
CRITICAL FOR PEOPLE WHO STRUGGLE
WITH ADDICTION. IF THIS MEASURE
DOES NOT INCREASE OUR CAPACITY
TO DO THAT, IT IS A FAILED
MEASURE. I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE WORK THAT YOU
ALL HAVE DONE AT THE LEGISLATIVE
LEVEL TO PASS SOLUTIONS AROUND
THINGS LIKE RETAIL THEFT. WE
SUPPORT OUR SMALL BUSINESSES. WE
SUPPORT THE RIGHT THAT EVERY
INDIVIDUAL HAS IN THIS STATE TO
BE SAFE. BUT I CAN TELL YOU, AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS LIVED MOST OF
THEIR LIFE FEELING UNSAFE AND
UNPROTECTED BY THE SYSTEMS, WHO
ARE SUPPOSED TO UPHOLD THAT,
THAT RELYING ON INCARCERATION
WILL NOT GET US THE OUTCOME THAT
WE WANT. I WANT TO YIELD THE
REST OF MY TIME AND TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE. THANK
YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS?
SEEING NONE BUT I DO APPRECIATE
YOUR PRESENTATION. I ALSO WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THAT ONE AGAIN, ONE
OF OUR FASTEST GROWING SUBSTANCE
ABUSERS TEND TO BE SENIORS. AND
SO INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
SUFFERING FROM ADDICTION ARE NOT
ALL THE SAME. THAT IS THE
STEREOTYPE IN PEOPLE'S MINDS.
AND AGAIN THEIR TREATMENT THEIR
SUPPORT VERY MUCH VARIES. SO YOU
HAVE AGAIN THE ONE TIME USER,
YOU HAVE THE STUDENT
EXPERIMENTING, YOU HAVE THE
PARTYGOER, AND THEN YOU HAVE
TRUE ADDICTS. SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT CLARIFICATION. I APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME. AGAIN. THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS. WE ARE ALLOTTING A
TOTAL OF 20 MINUTES FOR EVERYONE
TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK. HOWEVER,
THE PUBLIC COMMENTS CAN ONLY BE
YOUR NAME, YOUR ORGANIZATION IF
YOU REPRESENT ONE AND WHETHER OR
NOT YOU SUPPORT PROP 36. SORRY.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS ED LITTLE
WITH CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AND WE ARE OPPOSED TO
PROPOSITION 36. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, GLENN BECK'S FOR DRUG
POLICY ALLIANCE, NOT FOR DRUG
POLICY ALLIANCE. SORRY, THAT WAS
MY FORMER CLIENT. THE ELLA BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IS
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO PROP 36.
THANK YOU. PRISCILLA CðC, ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES AND
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU,
BOBBIE SINGH-ALLEN, REPRESENTING
2000 FROM THE AMERICAN PETROLEUM
AND CONVENIENCE STORE
ASSOCIATION AND THE MAYOR OF ELK
GROVE IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR PROP
36. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
ERIC HENDERSON, ON BEHALF OF
SMART JUSTICE CALIFORNIA. VÆ
LARA, CALIFORNIA. AND HÌ
CONSULTING AND OPPOSITION TO
PROP 36. GOOD MORNING, Dð COONEY
ON BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION IN OPPOSITION TO PROP 36.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. TISHA
STEPHENS WITH CATALYST
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG OPPOSITION
TO PROP 36. THANK YOU. HELLO
ANDREW BIANCHI WITH DECARCERATE
SACRAMENTO AND STRONG OPPOSITION
TO PROP 36 KATRINA REECE WITH
INITIATE JUSTICE.
&GT;&GT; KATRINA REECE WITH
INITIATE JUSTICE AND STRONG
OPPOSITION OF PROP 36.
&GT;&GT; COURTNEY HANSEN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
FOR WOMEN PRISONERS.
STRONG OPPOSITION TO 36.
&GT;&GT; SARAH BRENNAN ON BEHALF
OF NEXTGEN CALIFORNIA.
IN OPPOSITION.
&GT;&GT; GOOD MORNING PEDRO,
ALONG WITH CEO, CENTER FOR
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES.
SACRAMENTO.
STRONG OPPOSITION
TO PROPOSITION 36.
&GT;&GT; I WOULD ALSO OF CENTER
FOR EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
AND STRONG OPPOSITION
FOR THIS PROPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
&GT;&GT; APRIL GRAYSON, POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR SISTER FREEDOM
COALITION, IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF PROP 36.
&GT;&GT; EMILY WUNDER, ON BEHALF
OF THE YOUNG WOMEN'S FREEDOM
CENTER IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO PROPOSITION 36.
&GT;&GT; PAMELA SMITH, MOTHERS
AND GRIEF SUPPORT GROUP
IN FAVOR OF PROP 36.
REBECCA GONZALEZ, WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY
IN OPPOSITION TO PROP 36.
&GT;&GT; JIM LINDBERG, FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA.
FRIENDS COMMITTEE IS
RECOMMENDING A NO
VOTE ON PROP 36.
KELLI WALTERS.
&GT;&GT; STAFF ATTORNEY WITH
LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN.
AND ALL OF US ARE NONE.
ACTION NETWORK AND STRONG
OPPOSITION TO PROP 36.
&GT;&GT; HI, I'M BERNICE RODGERS WITH
INITIATE JUSTICE AND DREAMWORK.
I AM IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO PROP 36.
&GT;&GT; HI, I'M LAURA LARIOS WITH
INITIATE JUSTICE WITH STRONG
OPPOSITION ON PROP 36.
&GT;&GT; WE'RE HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE PRISONER'S VOICE
ORGANIZATION.
WE'RE VOTING NO ON
PROPOSITION 36.
HELLO AGAIN, TANYA STEPHENS,
ON BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE FOR
REPARATIONS,
RECONCILIATION AND TRUTH.
NO.
ON PROPOSITION 36.
GOOD MORNING, MICAH
DOKHTOUROFF, ON BEHALF OF ACLU
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA, IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO PROP 36.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
PUBLIC COMMENTS?
SEEING NONE, I'LL ALLOW ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO MAKE
THEIR FINAL STATEMENT.
ALL RIGHT.
AGAIN, WE APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S
PRESENTATION AND COMMENTARY.
I DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
THIS IS A VERY SENSITIVE
ISSUE TO MANY PEOPLE.
SO WE TRY TO BE AS FAIR
AS POSSIBLE IN THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
AND AGAIN WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION
AND JUST YOUR VIEWERSHIP.
SO THANK YOU.
AND MEETING ADJOURNED.
&GT;&GT; YES I JUST WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
AND ALSO I THINK THIS IS
THE LAST, LAST TIME THAT I WILL
SPEAK AS AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
SO.
ALL RIGHT.
FAIR, FAIR.
WELL, THANK YOU.
AND, UH, I'M SURE THE ELECTORATE
WILL VOTE ON THIS AND WEIGH IN,
AND I'M GLAD WE WERE ABLE TO
ENGAGE A LITTLE BIT TODAY.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.